on behalf of the joint
committees on fisheries and
aquaculture we are so grateful
you join us thank you so much
many Butte travel far and wide
to be a to be here today and
we cannot tell you how much
we appreciate your presence at
today's hearings can be focus
on a few issues one we're gonna
be providing an update on a
current ocean conditions in
the dungeon it's crap season
Dungeness crab as you all know
was one of California's oldest
and most storied commercial
fisheries the first commercial
commercial harvest took place
during the gold rush during
that just a few miles away
from where we're at today in
the San Francisco Bay we're
gonna be providing a full
briefing on ocean conditions
and challenges the crap please
faces as the season is now
in full swing in most parts
of the state portions of the
north coast remain close to
it due to elevated to mark
acid levels we're also going
to be providing a critical
update on the efforts the
state of California the golden
state's crap and hard working
environmental organizations
up and down the coast have
been making to avoid whale
entanglements during crab
season you're gonna hear
from the director of fish
and wildlife for the state of
California today about steps
the department legislature
the administration has taken
it will be taking in the
months ahead he's gonna be
focusing on the launch of
a first of its kind plan to
protect whales during crab
season his comments today and
we're gonna representation
on the increasing threat of
ship strikes on whales off
the California coast grateful
that the vice chair is here
assembly member stone from
Santa Cruz thank you so much
Mister vice chair for tendon
and for all of your work Sir
I and we are so grateful that
it's in the number fill team
from the great city by the bay
is here today we're gonna be
joined by senator Wiener here
in just a bit we also grateful
to the team here at the query
him up the bay for hosting
this hearing we're gonna be
hearing from their CEO here
in just a bit George Jacobs
quick update on tomorrow gas
at levels -- we typically
have doctor Rafe could delay
here from UC Santa Cruz he's
-- ocean scientists providing
tomorrow gas of level updates
and today he's traveling
instances regrets the bottom
line through his update is
demo gas a doubles in the
Pacific this year have been
trending upwards particularly
in northern California -- we
were very concerned because in
the beginning of -- the fall
the trains were looking like
two thousand fifteen which was
the worst on record Humboldt
del nor and seven organ have
emerge is hot spots along the
west coast however two thousand
eighteen appears to have peaked
in September and October and we
are now seen declining levels
of tomorrow gas it even in the
north by and we do not expect
and other state Y.
closure like we saw in the
disastrous crap year of two
thousand fifteen that said
I think that almost all this
can agree the Pacific go see
ocean is changing its sick
and we have a new reality in
front of us climate change is
no longer a theory it's here
in California's environment is
paying the price no matter how
many times are president says
climate change is a hoax it's
not going away our quality of
life our economy our health
in our environment will be
worse off because of climate
change and that's when the
reasons why we are here today
how we're gonna work together
in the months to come to be
able to focus on digits crap
ocean conditions as well as
protecting our majestic well
population at this point I'd
like to be able to turn the
floor over to our vice chair
by Sture stone I to be able
to offer opening comments and
we'll go to assembly member
team Mister vice chair the
for sure Sir thank you Mister
chair welcome everyone to this
hearing it's very interesting
time in one of the things
the secure that I very much
appreciate this committee
is done is it's really but
a bridge between a lot of
different stakeholders for some
very difficult issues as we
try and manage sustainable in
industries is simple fisheries
here in California ensure that
iconic species like the Selmon
it's androgynous crabs and
others are very much a part
of our policy making and how
we understand interactions
with the ocean we also have
to recognize the changes in
those oceans because of really
global changes that have
happened and the California
led the way with the climate
action so that just a couple
of months ago and what was very
interesting was California's
position internationally
with many many jurisdictions
coming for putting a number
of other states but countries
from around the world looking
for leadership out out of
California and the conversation
about what we do with some
of the changes that we are
saying so the first couple
presenters we have from Los
protection council and from
fish and wildlife show some
of the bridges and connections
that we need to maintain
and as we head into a new
administration I think this
committee can be very important
in in helping to continue to
provide those bridges between
all of the stakeholders as
we deal with issues around
the crap fisheries impacts
on other wildlife that we
want to protect but also
understanding ways that we
can look at broader policy
to ensure that the oceans
are healthy is that's a part
of sustainable fisheries as
well I've had the opportunity
over this last year to go
to a number of meetings and
conferences one most recently
at at the muscle any marine
lab which is the CSU's marine
lab on aquaculture and tied
into all of this and tied into
the sustainable fisheries is
California's position or lack
of position with aquaculture
and I think that's something
that this committee is also
very interested in looking at
I know she protection councils
of added as are the the
departments and I'm hoping that
over the next few weeks engage
with the administration look
at barriers to the challenges
to the aquaculture industry
in a productive way so that
we can can look at Especiales
shellfish and some of the the
at the algae sea weeds that
are currently being produced in
California but in fairly small
numbers that I think that there
are ways that we can bridge
that but without the science
behind the changes that are
going on without understanding
of the breadth of the issues
around fisheries then we're
always going to be coming up I
think a little bit short from
a policy standpoint and that's
why I think this committee and
then we really should Mister
chair can be a very good
focal point for a lot of these
discussions whether it's well
entanglements whether it's
looking at ocean acidification
and changes in chemistry that
fact tensely seafood industries
we can have conversations about
the regulatory environment
and working with regulating
agencies so that they can
fulfill their mission we can
protect the environment we
can protect the state state
ability of fisheries but also
ensure the economic viability
of some of these pieces that
are very report to California
and to California's economy
so this is this is going to
be very interesting hearing
but I'm also looking ahead at
next year and get making sure
that this committee is well
positioned to continue those
conversations work with the
incoming administration on some
of these issues and really look
to Friday California's strength
when it comes the oceans and
fisheries thank you Mister vice
chair very eloquent I think
you're absolutely right -- both
on all issues of conditions
within the Pacific I think
the other issue that we're
going to take a look at this
coming year is -- which were
excited about is wind energy
-- but that development off
the coast and what that may
need for fisheries are -- re
monuments as well as the fleet
into that something else that
we're gonna be I take a look at
as we move forty and it really
looking forward to you Mister
vice chair -- on all issues
coming up in two thousand
nineteen you want to say thank
you to assembly member team I
was also chair of the assembly
budget committee on he is here
today aimed at a member of
this committee in he's been
such a champion for all issues
fisheries and aquaculture some
member the floors research
thank you Mister chairman
and Mister vice chair just --
really appreciate both your
work on this particular issue
-- just echo -- my colleague
Mister stone's comments like
they think of some of our
larger challenges that we've
been working on all of the last
number of years is really about
sustainability making sure that
we can have a thriving industry
that sustainable -- long term
that is also grappling with
many of the environmental
factors that we've all had to
do with over the last couple
of years -- so very much again
look forward to being part of
this committee -- this year
this is I'm going -- this is
my sixty one the committee
that's been -- I think --
extraordinary work but -- it's
been really an honor to be able
to work with such an amazing
industry for our state thank
you thank you so much Mister
someone number you wanna remind
folks that were streaming live
today on Senate dot CA dot god
will also be archiving today's
hearing we want to say thank
you to our chief consultant to
my left Mister Tom puesto for
all of his work for hearing is
well I and we now would like
to be able to bring up George
Jacobs chief executive officer
at the aquarium of the bay at
this check up thank you so much
for hosting us and this is such
a fantastic facility and we're
grateful for your hospitality
the floor is yours Sir
check welcome to -- equity
by the bay California's only
Smithsonian affiliated a query
-- be house about twenty four
thousand adults one hundred
thirty species and -- falling
the climate summit -- in
September -- we decided to
unveil the vision for the
first climate museum notion
conservation center in the US
right here the current site
-- and with a quickly share
a few slides of what this
two hundred million dollar
project would look like -- we
are fortunate to have with us
-- Dr Jill Biden last month
-- for the formal unveiling
of a very detailed version
of this -- this project
-- we are an amalgam of six
branches so agreement bay
is only one of them we run
the eco center part for the
port -- in a database and the
bay academy the Bates to it
on the bay model for the US
army corps of engineers in
Sausalito and -- also see line
center which is on the other
side of the act that the docks
those are some of a lease
properties of corporate
offices across the street
be employed one hundred and
seventy five people and over
three hundred volunteers the
welcome about seventy thousand
visitors each year this year
the two as number seven down
but with this new climate and
motion conservation museum
we are hoping to attract
to two million visitors a
year -- there are fifteen
million visitors a complete
the Embarcadero each year so
by comparison told me income
to the Golden Gate Bridge
in fifty million come to the
Embarcadero so we thought that
if we can tap into five or
ten percent of that number --
we will have an evangelized
climate literacy and resilience
at leadership for tomorrow
so you get a sense of the
scope and scale of the project
-- people working with an
international team of experts
for the last eighteen months
-- in about eight thousand
hours of work into this --
edifice and its C.
early platinum building --
which has photo by reactors
uses when power it is --
powered by Michael brick
using fish waste and it has
a lot of nuances in all the
topics that Mr waste your
message here mentioned earlier
on including the my gas and
ocean acidification sea level
rise sequel Michael plastics
disruptive technologies
they're all part of this
conversation including
celebrating climate heroes
it gives you a visual
on what the Senate would
look like hundred sixty
thousand square feet with
three acres of activated
green space between peers
thirty five and thirty nine
since the deep ocean
exploration centre
in debts that shows you in
relation to Alcatraz what the
premise would look like I just
wanna and and by saying that
be delighted to host you here
and somebody we have noticed in
your honor we have a be a mural
in the back and said -- painted
by an artist from Thomas which
we just -- unveiled a couple
of weeks ago as the exact
size of a baby humpback whale
with fifteen feet thank you
and welcome eighty so much
just give a round of applause
for executive answer please
again we're very grateful for
your hospitality Sir and thank
you for all of your work and
we look forward to seeing these
plans come to fruition as well
Sir thank you so much it's good
to see you thank you we also
want to say thank you to the
entire team at the aquarium for
all of their work in helping
us get set up and get in this
hearing move thank you so much
we'd like to be removed for
first panel now we're gonna
have remarks from a bill that
would never have percent cheese
the ocean protective council
executive director also the
deputy secretary for oceans
of coastal policy into the
California natural resources
agency we're also hearing
from Mister Chuck Bonta music
director of the California
department of fish wildlife
-- please view to wouldn't
mind coming forward on this
however status can be focusing
a report on ocean acidification
as well as efforts on Whalen
turtle entanglement and their
support of the well working
group in the dungeon it's crap
task is the director is going
to be focusing his comments
on the monumental efforts that
the city California's been
advancing a in regards to well
entanglement and the launch of
a first ago first of its kind
program here in the United
States of America out working
with the federal government
this have reset the floors
yours thank you so much you
have seven minutes and we are
so grateful for all the work or
happy you're here with us today
thank you very much chairman
and thank you assemblyman stone
and assemblyman saying it's
a pleasure to be here today
-- again I'm the executive
director of the California
mission protection counsel
and deputy secretary friction
coastal matters resources
agency which is a mouthful
and but at our mission really
is to protect and conserve
the ocean and you mentioned a
couple of threats that and that
the ocean is facing right now
one is entanglement which I'll
discuss a bit and the other
is climate change which just
infuses all of the work that
we do and affects the ocean so
significantly and in relation
to Wayland payment OPC since
September twenty fifteen has
been working to identify and
to reduce the risks and Waylon
team woman and in dungeons
crab fishing year we work very
closely with city of W.
with no way to convene and a
really unique and effective
collaboration and fishermen
NGOs and federal and state
partners -- in order to you
think three to and how to best
address and reduce the risk of
will entertainment specifically
intention is practicing here
and we provided a grant to
the nature Conservancy to
administer facilitate this
group which I'm going to call
the the whale entanglement
working group it's also known
as the tension is kind of
fishing gear working group that
that gets confusing because
there's also Dennis got task
force and so I will stick with
just calling it a will working
group so the will working
group the last couple of years
has worked on developing a
risk assessment in mitigation
program and to determine where
it when the risk containment
is elevated and to identify
measures to reduce that risk
it's called the ramp and the
ramp was highlighted -- in
the last couple of seasons and
under Senate bill thirteen oh
nine by senator required and
it was codified and the working
group it's also codified
legislatively and and director
Bonham was given the authority
to implement management
measures and in the event
of elevated risk so the real
really represents an innovative
effective partnership that's
based on approach to develop
solutions to decrease
the risk of entanglement
in concert with that program
OPC also receive seven point
five million dollars this year
in the budget and assembly
member take a to address the
way on sea turtle entanglement
and and we have been working
with the way on the woman
working group to identify
appropriate projects that
will help reduce that risk
and and and separate out the
the crab fishing if you're
having a thriving crab fishery
and having a very thriving
we'll completion were really
relying on the ramp program
to identify those projects
that that we need to implement
and we have both short term
high priority projects that
were identifying as well as
I'm developing a lot more
long term holistic investment
strategy and to the budget
was at became effective July
one we've already implemented
to projects and one was at
a grant to the California
will rescue to support and
I fishing dynamics and well
concentration data collection
and program through the use of
solar lawmakers Anne's solar
loggers are being deployed
on forty commercial fishing
vessels as well as twenty
well watching and passenger
vessels any idea there is to
be able to collect data from
both the fishermen who are
out and doing their work and
from the wheel watchers you
least theoretically identifying
where the well populations are
and then bringing that data
together performing analytics
on it performing visualization
and developing things like maps
so that we can really see very
clearly where the crap where
the wheels and and think about
ways to avoid entanglement
and interaction the other
grant that we provided was a
million dollars to the wildlife
health center at let's run
through UC Davis I'm in that
supports the California marine
mammal stranding network and
for stealing and seal rescue
that was and actually -- --
specific appropriation as
part of the seven point five
million and and we've we've
already provided that you the
wildlife health center in order
to address and remain standing
in addition to the well working
group we wouldn't working
very closely with and then
attention is caught task force
and in since two thousand
eight actually a PC has been
designated as the body that's
responsible for convening
this task force and under
another piece of legislation
by senator required and we
will be able to continue
administering the task force in
partnership with city of W.
and and it is a separate
administrative team and
part of that legislation
SB thirteen ten update the
tension is packed task force
election process -- and so
we are working again very
closely with city of W.
downline a process and the
timing for the next election
because there's some changes
in the composition of the
task force I do you just want
to note -- that as a world
where there's going to be a
new administration starting
in January so for the members
of the task force that are
appointed by the chair and
the ocean protection council
with the secretary of natural
resources there will be a
delay you know and so we
have a new secretary in place
turning now to our work on
commission acidification
and more the climate change
threats and that that proposed
to the ocean the wildlife
and fisheries and the OPC
adopted in October and ocean
acidification action plan
and this is a ten year action
plan and and it fulfills
one of our commitments as a
founding member of the ocean
acidification alliance and and
access acts as a model we hope
for an for other jurisdictions
who are who are members have
this alliance the idea is
to have tractable actionable
steps that can be taken over
the next ten years to mitigate
ameliorate the realities of
ocean acidification and we
first became aware of ocean
acidification from the the
harm that was being faced by
Washington state when they're
western countries and their
oyster industry collapsed and
and we've been working closely
with Washington Oregon British
Columbia and now seventy eye
there at international the
jurisdictions to address ocean
acidification I I do want
to just point out that the
science right now is indicating
that the harm is not limited
to mollusks is not limited
to oysters there is and the
potential for it in implicate
crab reduplicated salmon and
so the time this is really a
critical moment when we need
to be focused on an ocean
acidification and how we are
going to and mitigate those
impacts and so that's what
this plan does and we're now
that it's past we're working
already in implementing and
the various steps included in
and finally I just wanted to
note that down the street today
and California's track of fish
two point oh kick dot and that
is a really exciting anything
innovative partnerships
and it's a global program
that incubates pioneering
sustainable seafood businesses
and brings them together
brings together investors
seafood entrepreneurs fishermen
public agencies NGOs to really
think through innovative
new approaches to developing
sustainable seafood and
sustainable fishing programs
and California and a P.
C. supported this track and
it has three main goals one
is to -- address traceability
and transparency one is to
and develop innovations in
sustainable local food systems
and the fishing communities
and the third is to increase
resilience to climate change
I'm so we're really excited
to see that moving forward and
and there will be a competition
and winners will be announced
tomorrow so I with that I and
I turn it over to director on
thank you so much and Weber
sector you very grateful for
your work Mister director we're
grateful for your hearing --
they -- as the director is
coming in -- it is being --
an incredible tenure offer him
-- both when it comes to the
sea disasters that we faced
as well as on land with all
the fires as one take a moment
to say thank you and your
team up for all the work and
what I mean talking about I
cannabis legalization as well
so -- which is available for
that houses his that he may
need some at the end of his
tenure so -- it's running thank
you so much for being here
-- what grateful for all of
your work -- in here cannabis
because well boisterous
so the floor is yours
thank you senator co chairs
down assembly member ting
secretary it's true my name
is Chuck bottom and I'm the
director of the California
department of fish and wildlife
just by way of forecast
later today you'll hear from
doctor creek Chiu minute the
department he will have all
the specific details around
the general Dungeness crab
season outlook the disaster
relief process quality testing
-- mark as a testing and then
after that you will also hear
from some key monster that
the department who will walk
you through the operational
details of the risk assessment
mitigation program that is
right secretary announced
in my time I want to step
back I want to offer a few
reflections -- based on almost
the eight years as director and
charter vision which I think
you share with our department
and everyone in the room and
also when I try to make a
little bit lives so crowds
are big deal in California
they're one of our oldest and
most valuable fisheries and
I don't know about where I
grew up the floor of the all
is all you all what all you
all have on your holiday menus
at home but I have Dodge's
problem and then you come
the crabs also supplied jobs to
our coastal communities up and
down the state but it's equally
true whales are really big
deal I mean literally there the
most majestic largest animal
swimming off of our Richard
sure and I would say that what
our department has done with
a very broad set of partners
to prevent well entanglement
in fishing gear in the last
couple years is a big deal also
this state California's home
to more biodiversity than
any other state in these
United States biodiversity
is a measure of the richness
of life our ocean waters
are home to one of the most
productive marine ecosystems
in the world and California's
consistently rank very high
protection of our ocean
but in two thousand fifteen
something happened that was
pretty disturbing to everyone
in this room we saw rising
wait a rate of Wales entangled
in fishing gear the number
of reported entanglements
jumped in two thousand fifteen
and two thousand sixteen
but dropped considerably in
two thousand seventeen in
two thousand eight and that
dropped by some accounts was
as much as by eighty percent
but the spike in two
thousand fifteen and sixteen
corresponded with things we've
never seen in the ocean it
corresponded with a change
in ocean temperature then
tagged as the warm water
and we saw a corresponding
change in the abundance and
location of the food that
whales which is krill and
small fish so because it is
Ocean change the whales chase
their food closer to shore
and that brought them into
traditional fishing grounds
in in those fishing grounds in
those years was an unusually
high concentration of year
for crabbing because we had
an unprecedented delay in
the season from incredibly
high levels of the mall the
gas in in some since we had
an unholy convergence of
these several factors any
corresponded to that dramatic
uptick in entanglements we
were all concerned about
it even one whale or turtle
entanglement is too many and
that's why the department
and our partners took swift
action in two thousand fifteen
as you've heard mention
by the deputy secretary we
establish this working with
my next point is membership
is really key to me it should
be key to you as well in
membership drives our future
here's what I mean this
working group is comprised of
commercial and recreational
fishermen in one it includes
environmental organizations
some of whom you'll hear from
today it includes members of
the disentangle my network it
includes marine mammal experts
and resource managers we formed
in two thousand fifteen and
they adopted one unifying
principle they were gonna
support both a robust Dungeness
crab fishery in reduce well
into mutually exclusive
because of their work our
department has at a platform
to take specific action so here
are some of the things we've
done in the last two years
we have informed all crabbers
that everybody must check
their gear every ninety six
hours during the season we've
created a program to retrieve
derelict fishing gear from the
ocean which senator you sparked
-- with your leadership in
legislation we've collaborated
with industry to develop will
friendly year we've actually
adopted new rules and got them
in place before the season
began limiting the number of
trailer bill is in a link to
fishing line that can be used
and with clarified through
the voice of our wildlife
officers that everyone must
remove their fishing gear at
the end of the crab season and
we're going to enforce that
since we're in San Francisco
I'd be remiss if I didn't say
tech can happen can help to
hear you heard a description
of some of the technology
that's been invested in with
seed funding by the protection
council but the point here
is we can do better we can
get more immediate transfer
of water observations in
ocean conditions both from
our beliefs and our will
watching vessels we can force
that information into better
analytical platforms give
the information to those
in the working group we can
make instantaneous decisions
to try to manage this risk
profile technology can help
here will and were marching
along that path but I would
argue the single most important
change comes from senator
your legislation SB thirty
no not most people don't
realize our crowd fisheries
primarily governed by the laws
established in the legislative
process the department then and
previous to this bill we had
no authority to take certain
actions we now do we now
have the specific legislative
authority for the first
time to implement time area
closures as needed gear density
restrictions for require
specialized equipment but I
would say even perhaps more
importantly SB thirteen oh
nine memorializes the working
group formalizes their role
and breathe life into their
great work going forward
I think what's happened in the
last two years is probably the
most progressive and protective
commitment by any state
in the United States to deal
with the way on tackle the
problem but I also think
we can do more nobody wants
wells entanglement entangled
the turtles and take with you
don't we don't our federal
counterparts stone hard working
members the crap please don't
environmental organizations
don't so huge shout out to
my hometown paper the San
Francisco Chronicle some of
you might have seen a published
an opinion editorial last
night this morning I'm going
to confirm the news with
broken that opinion editorial
last night our department
gave formal notice to our
federal colleagues at the no
with fisheries agency within
the department of commerce
that we intend to submit a
conservation plan to minimize
and hopefully eliminate the
risk of entanglements from
archive fisheries and to
receive approval under the
federal Endangered Species
Act for the conservation I
checked no other state agency
to our knowledge is taking
its commitment to protecting
marine mammals thus far
me divert for one second
climate change it's not
theoretical it's not just
a scientific issue it's a
real it's painful and it's
causing impacts the people
and things we care about
two thousand fifteen and
sixteen was a problem
because of our changing ocean
conditions the movement of
our large mammals in the
ocean the interface -- with
our fishing community because
of a on usual to mark as a
situation that may happen in
the future more not less this
conservation plan we're going
to do will help us get a headed
will help us secure
federal approvals and that
leads me to our vision
as you heard mention the OPC
has seven point five million
dollars to this effort at our
department we now have staff
thank you senator McGuire
and subcommittee for budget
and assembly member ting our
department and governor brown
leadership working with you has
produced specifics that would
be dedicated to the will and
hang on that issue and here's
the vision I think the vision
is a future where crap stays
on a holiday menus forever
where coastal communities are
thriving and resilience in the
face of a warming climate and
changing ocean conditions and
where we can all look westward
look out into that magnificent
Pacific Ocean and see whales
and turtles swimming and our
marine environment free from
the risk of entanglement it's
a good vision sound vision to
feasible vision we asked the
support of everyone in getting
there together so with that
let me pause and see if you
have any questions for the
defense secretary for me thank
you so much Mister director
we like that opening up to the
committee for ask questions we
will be going to public comment
twice in two days agenda once
after agenda item three in in
another time after item six at
this time we like to go to ask
the committee Mister vice chair
sitting
this one if you can just walk
us through what this process
looks like -- its first of
its kind the only state in the
union that will be advancing a
plan like this walk us through
what this looks like an I
think some will com is that
going first it's too risky
but my rebuttal would be it's
okay to be first California
typically go face first on a
Tana's that makes a difference
nationally and internationally
being first can often solidify
your position as a leader
even though going through
something for the first time
is awful and more painful
so I don't have a precise
road map senator but here's
what I would predict are some
of the pieces that will be
in are coming days months
first in my view we have
the group assembled it's
are working group they need
to stay together we need to
keep supporting them with
investment a capacity we need
to let them shape substance
I see a submission of an
application to our federal
sister agency it would define
a conservation plan you could
look at the impact of the any
activity on the whales are
turtles it would illustrate
steps to monitor and embrace
technology it would define
the measures we would take
to minimise and mitigate any
impacts it could walk through a
series of actions it hopefully
will embrace the ramp program
which is already well under
way -- we would need public
comment as we go through the
federal Endangered Species
Act process we would like we
need an environmental kind
of document platform for the
eventual permitting decision
on the federal front -- it's
possible we would -- go out
to public comment these are
a lot of decisions that would
be incumbent upon our federal
sister agency we would feel
responses and then we would
do it -- rations of our
conservation plan based on
that feedback and eventually
-- I see something being
approved I see something
memorializing are working group
and I see something producing
a conservation plan in the
regulatory certainty that are
crap fleet needs onto a federal
permit will it take a month
ago is going to be easy not
-- is a year eighteen months
two years I think a little
bit of that is determinative
upon assembling this crowd and
laying out of time on because
we are going first a he said
that in your right being the
first is always a risk I think
the risk is greater -- if
there is no action required by
the state of California right
I agree -- and needing to be
able to move as quickly and as
thoroughly as possible excuse
me I apologize and find a call
today -- in know that this is
being a lot of work community
days hearing to be able to
make this announcement -- are
you gonna need some additional
resources as we move forward
well that's a great question
given the leadership on the
panel across from me on my
budget front I look for to that
conversation if I'm director
in two thousand nineteen and we
go through the budget process
I would also remind folks
listening this is not the only
thing our department will be
doing your SB thirteen oh nine
yeah requires us to complete
state based rule making some
of which we started some of
which we've completed other
provisions we need to advance
to the end that will allow
us to memorialize and state
law and structure the ramp
the working group -- and we
have a deadline in the state
statute to complete all that
work so in my mind we will be
harmonizing multiple regulatory
platforms to win in goal which
is that vision I describe
the two thousand fifteen we
had about ten wailing tackle
means on average but we peak
in two thousand fifteen of
the California coast a fifty
billion with the forty eight
and sixteen N. F.
pretty a significant decrease
in two thousand seventeen
thirty one -- a what I'll say
the reason why I bring that up
is when we saw that peak year
two thousand fifteen which was
the worst year also for crap
-- immediately jumped into
action -- a now we wanted to
create a foundation for success
success for my reading and
feeding whales in the future
-- as well as -- another strong
century for California story
crap please I am very grateful
for that I think the other
item that we need to be able
to discuss of which we will --
later today is issue of ship
strikes so -- we have been
very focused on all issues
seven tango and rightfully so
is unacceptable these numbers
that we have in front of us
are simply unacceptable I which
is why you're department and
hundreds from across the state
of the working out with the
fleet to be able to limit the
number ten comments and to be
able to get that two zero and
what's not talked about is
a number of whales that are
being killed every year with
commercial vessels and that is
also a growing concern I know
for this committee is we would
for I don't know if there's
any item that you would like
to be able to come in a way
to set if I'm still director
in two thousand nineteen I
would be working and focusing
on that issue as well I'm very
grateful -- Mister director for
all your efforts on the case
hearing get the secretary for
a group of your effort I know
that -- it's just beginning --
my last question for you you've
been having conversations with
your federal counterparts --
an airborne to be able start
looking for correct yes --
I think you may hear some
of that later today we have
a very productive working
relationship with our west
coast counterparts on federal
agency Nazarian fisheries
service nama and late yesterday
I spoke with the western
regional administrator about
our department's attention and
it was a positive conversation
that's great but I could see
if there's any comments from
the committee we follow up
in Texas Debbie sector think
so much Mister director thank
you for being here we're very
grateful for your time thank
you as we transition to our
next panel we do want to let
everyone know were maybe having
a small reception immediately
following hearing how we're
grateful that a hog island
as well as -- seafood for
bringing in fresh oysters and
we're going to be happen crap
is well we wanna think Reagan
John Robb for all of their
support on that and everyone
is welcome we now would like to
be able to move to our second
panel of the day this panels
can be focusing on charges crap
in the season tomorrow gas in
the quality testing a disaster
relief updates if we could
please have doctor Sherman
please come for doctor Sherman
is the manager of the marine
region for the California
department of fish and wildlife
he's gonna be providing an
overview the status for crab
season crap quality issues as
well as the current status of
the federal fishery disaster
declaration were also great for
the been seen he is here he's
chief food safety section --
the chief of the food safety
section for the California part
in a public health he is on
the other side of the coin when
it comes to testing we have to
go out and capture and then we
have the test -- through the
department of public health
and we're grateful that you are
here today is well Mister yee
he's gonna be providing a brief
overview of the tomorrow gas
a testing process -- and some
concerns that we still have
particularly on the north coast
we also going to be what we
know Oppenheim he's a executive
director of the Pacific coast
federation of fishermen's
association he represents
-- crabbers and fishermen
up and down the California
coast he's gonna be given is
a state of the state if you
will of the crab season in the
process and distribution of
disaster relief for since the
two thousand fifteen sixteen
season we're gonna ask each
for prisoners if you don't mind
pulling that microphone close
to you -- just because we're
having some challenges hearing
folks -- on the web so we're
gonna start out today with a
doctor should the technician
you have five minutes Sir
we welcome you committee
thank you so much for being
here we will go to committee
coming in questions in the
public comment after this
panel action morning senator
McGuire culture stone assembly
member Chiang store was low
thank you for the opportunity
to speak before you today
and correction memory region
manager California department
official wildlife and I'm
gonna give you a brief update
on the general season outlook
for Dungeness crab demote
testy in disaster relief in
implementation of SB thirteen
ten women and try to do have
all in five minutes or less
open on time on November third
in all areas except for the
area from Patrick's point
Humboldt County north to the
California Oregon border that
area remains closed due to
elevated levels of demo like
acid in the meat of testing
crab -- this is something
that's new we typically don't
close the recreational fishery
from a recommendation from
the health agencies we had
elevated levels in the meat
issues of that something we are
keeping tabs on we are getting
reports of good catches from
the recreational fleet and
lots of reports of short crowds
of people are already very
excited about next season on
the commercial front this other
central management area open
on time on November fifteenth
in all areas except for the
area from bodega head north
to the cinema Mendocino county
line due to elevated levels of
too much acid in the district
tested crap weekly testing
is occurring in partnership
with public health and the
fleet to test samples at a
restaurant try to get that area
in the northern management
area quality testing commenced
in early November and the
guidelines established by
the tri state Dungeness crab
committee in coordination
with the California department
of public health to verify
areas that are clear tonight
gas it were testing can occur
results from the November
third testing let were low
quality meat so that led to
a notice from director bottom
on November twentieth to
delay the fishery to December
sixteenth the second round
of quality testing will occur
around December first two
discernment to determine if
we delay until December thirty
first if me quality is still
low another round of testing
will occur to determine if
we delayed until January
fifteenth I'm last season we
are not able to test beyond
January first for quality
but new authority provided by
Sen requires SB thirteen ten
enables us to continue testing
be on January first of the
season will not be delayed
past January fifteenth so that
testing can occur to help the
fleet with a market choices
-- demo gas and only the
details to make our privacy
at -- California department
of public health but I will
highlight that on this is been
a long road force we've learned
a lot in the last three years
-- we've gotten a lot better
at it and I want to thank my
colleagues at the department
of public health at the office
environmental health hazard
assessment and also the fleet
we still have a long way to
go this is a new program --
we lacked they're sufficient
resources and infrastructure
to make this a permanent long
term program that's something
I think we should all keep
on our radar one of the ways
we are trying to address that
is through some of portion
of the disaster relief funds
so in early September the
department submitted to spend
plan to the Pacific states
bring fisheries commission to
distribute twenty five and a
half million dollars a disaster
funds to California dungeon is
a rock crap fisheries the vast
majority those funds eighty
nine percent will go towards
direct payments to those fleets
with the balance going towards
mitigation programs at a
small piece to P.
S. NFC overhead the drafting
of the spending plan was
facilitated by extensive out
reach with affected entities
including to web meetings
to share the pro spending
plan to solicit feedback
the department intends to
solicit request for proposals
and establish a stakeholder
advisory group to help develop
criteria and priorities for use
of the mitigation funds we're
still working on the details
of that approach and welcome
any feedback from the committee
or stakeholders all of the
details of the spend plan the
timeline are highlighted on
our website and frequently
asked questions document as
is the proposal so I will go
to those details here -- I'm
happy to answer any questions
you might have regarding the
-- highlights of SB thirteen
ten for the dentures crap
fisheries of new approaches for
this year first I wish to thank
senator require your staff
especially Tom less low for
your leadership on all things
that just grabbed -- recent
changes to the passage of SB
thirteen ten include changes
to fair start language that
will apply fair start to any
area of ocean waters subject
to a delay in the season opener
and to find a delay to the
tri state quality or human
health risk delays when areas
that are delayed are open the
director now has a story to
provide set up to seventy two
hour notice between outs in
an open area and when the gear
set time begins and this area
was will not include holidays
and some we ran into previous
seasons of this having clean
that gives us some structure
these new rules will apply to
the Russian river area when it
eventually opens -- frequently
asked question document was
posted on our website in early
November you can imagine we
got a lot of questions from the
fleet so all that information
is on our website it will be
updated as areas continue to
open up we've also been working
with our license revenue branch
of law enforcement vision to
update vessel size requirements
to establish a baseline link
for dungeons craft also permits
-- this also generated a lot
of questions from the fleet so
we've posted another frequently
asked questions document on our
website and to try to answer
those questions in closing I
want to thank the committee
for your interest in your
leadership on all things crab
-- I want to recognize the
fleet this hasn't been easy
for them want to thank our NGO
and agency partners and I also
want to recognize department
staff -- particularly
Cristian sees a in the back
Christie rate raise your hand
so three three years ago
Christie's only job was to
serve on the Dennis crap task
force and then she became our
demo gas at asper are well
expert and is just another
finally get some additional
resources to ease some of that
burden on her every time we
open and airy or close an area
it's a flurry of documents
that need to get signed by
the director that need to go
out of press releases the need
to get updated on the website
-- I mentioned at least three
frequently asked question
documents and put together this
year and and Christie's really
been responsible for a lot
of that -- to that -- closing
happy answer any questions you
have at the in the testimony
is measures should be would you
want to say thank you Christy
it is not an easy three years
-- and -- incredibly stressful
on a lot connect yeah and we're
very grateful for all of your
efforts to please pass on our
things to everyone back at the
department in which she when
I think you you hit the nail
on the head it's been -- one
of the most challenging times
in the history of the crap
commercial harvest at least
-- having a closure in fifteen
sixteen devastated many rural
communities many real close
of committees up and down the
state that the funding that
was she was discusses about
twenty six million they came
from the federal government
disaster relief wow that is
not going to help a hundred
percent of what was lost --
it was -- absolutely necessary
unfortunately took quite a
long time to be able to get
it delivered but we do want
to say thank you to Congress
would have been as well as
congressman Thompson -- in
Congress woman spear for their
efforts they were instrumental
in bringing that forward there
are two sides of testing of
crap obviously you have the
department of fish wildlife
and then you have -- mystery
and focusing on tests and --
the -- the meat at the crab and
making sure that it checks out
printer over the mystery you
to be a gives a update on all
issues the judges crab season
what he's seen from those
tests are you have five minutes
certainly thank you for all of
your work it's good to see Sir
good afternoon Mister chairman
vice chair assembly member ting
and Mister Russell local you
for inviting us here today --
my name again is Nancy and I'm
the food safety section chief
of the department of public
health of the drug food and
drug branch I'm here today to
provide you with an update on
the post harvests the mode acid
testing and focusing on crabs
and the recent lobster data
I also want to acknowledge in
the audience -- doctor David
was era and our -- who is our
division chief and our program
specialists Cristina grant
was been a instrumental in our
in our work here within our
department there are multiple
programs that work closely
together to monitor potential
impacts and risks of harmful
algal blooms in the ocean the
governmental management branch
monitors bloom conditions
in the ocean a potential pre
harvest risk and impacts while
the food and drug branch where
I work monsters postharvest
risk in impacts on seafood
products had two servers
food drug laboratory branch
performs the more as a testing
on the fish and shellfish the
department in coordination with
the California department of
fish and wildlife and industry
which are who are critical
partners has begun pieces
the pre season testing of the
mode acid endogenous crabs we
have been watching the data
come in and hoping to see all
of the sampling points below
action levels unfortunately
we have two areas to the north
and the Russian river area
with samples above the thirty
parts per million action level
I'll provide an update on
the current advisories in
effect and then summarize
the results right someone
of for our slide here
we'll just do that manually
for you if you just want to
shout it out okay great great
thank you advisories are
currently are in fact in the
following areas Dungeness crab
caught in state waters from
Patrick's point in Trinidad
to crescent city that was
issued back in October twenty
fourth Dungeness crab caught
in the state waters around
Russian river in the database
area issued back on November
first -- rock crab caught
in state waters around Santa
Rosa island and or the Channel
Islands in Santa Barbara county
issue back in may two thousand
seventeen rock rap caught in
state waters north in minutes
you know county to the Oregon
border issued back in April two
thousand eighteen number to go
into the data -- the results
as of eleven -- November twenty
six two thousand eighteen
results from the two thousand
eighteen pre season testing
of dungeons crowd the most
recent sample sets are from
north to south St George
reef with hundreds and six
craps above the action level
Trinidad north or seventy
percent or one of six crabs
above the action level Eureka
all crappy little action level
what brag all grass below
action level the database
seventy percent or one of six
from the Russian river area
or exceeding the action level
half moon bay all and sexist
go all crappie low action level
Monterey and all crowds below
the action level immoral bay
all crappie love action level
switching gears the lobster
data as of November twenty
six lobster results are the
following the California
part public I'll only receive
samples from the Ventura and
Santa Barbara channel area in
late September lobster from
the and a cap on it exceeded
the federal action level twenty
parts per million or as high
as two hundred ten part million
additional samples were tested
from October and November
which have tested below the
limit the number of November
test results clout C.
PH to lift the health advisory
originally issued back in
October seventeenth for
lobster vysera cart around
and a couple islands in Santa
Barbara and Ventura counties
as a reminder of action over
democ acid and lobsters is
twenty park million in internal
go organs or the visceral
or cuts if you may -- of the
and the meat even increase
in Boston even in preseason
testing when eight location
comes back with the decedent's
we require to clean set seven
days apart to remove advisory
to go back in a little bit
talk about our postharvest
testing or department routinely
test the crab restaurant and
-- guts and other species
such as lobster etcetera and
up to this year's preseason
testing typically only tested
to meet with concentration
the bizarre or at high levels
typically over a hundred parts
per million for this lobster
and crab season C.
PH with the support from the
office of environmental health
hazard assessment is testing
to meet all animals exceeding
thirty parts per million in
order to gather additional data
in a line with the testing done
in Oregon and Washington C.
P. H. works with the California
fish department of fish and
wildlife to coordinate with
fishermen in the designated
areas ports of landing along
the coast industry support has
been critical and I repeat has
been instrumental in critical
in obtaining additional
samples with the impacted
area so our department can
make a determination as to
the potential risks to public
health we wish to thank them
publicly for the hard work
and support the provide to us
our department has been and
continues to post results on
the website up folks can do a
search -- for food drug branch
là mÙt acid and the public
industry and NEC interested
stakeholder may check the
website for updated information
as a reminder see page has
the no ability to modify
the -- le alert levels their
set at the federal level we
are required by federal and
state law to enforce these
level as are other states
I have some information
from other states as well
-- on October eighteenth two
thousand eighteen the Oregon
department of agriculture
and organ department of fish
and wildlife and out the
commercial and recreational
closer all crabbing on nor on
the southern Oregon coast to
the California border due to
elevated levels of demonic acid
the Washington department
of health have reported low
to non detectable levels
of demo Cassidy razor clams
and mussels Washington fish
and wildlife has not had any
fishery closures related to
crabs in closing I want to
thank you for your time and
for inviting us today realize
sickening six the significance
of our actions and I'm here
to reaffirm the department
of public health is committed
to working closely with our
partners agencies fishermen
and associated industry and the
legislature to provide timely
and relevant information thank
you thank you so much Mister
you were very grateful we're
gonna hold questions until we
hear from Mr often nine this
is our state of the state if
you will -- the crab fishery
you heard from both departments
now who are managing the
fisheries wells focusing on
public health we're now going
to hear from the fleet itself
-- and that's no Oppenheim
about what they are seeing
out in the ocean this year
strap ninety of five minutes
to for shores thank you Mister
chairman Mister vice chairman
assembly member ting in the
store was slow -- on behalf
of the fleet -- welcome to the
port of San Francisco we are
sitting here not three hundred
yards from the beating heart
of the bay area's commercial
fishing industry onions no
often I'm I'm the executive
director of the Pacific coast
federation of fishermen's
associations representing
fourteen organizations --
from Santa Barbara to the
Oregon border bringing healthy
sustainable Denton this crab
and other public trust seafood
resources to the dinner plates
of Californians Americans in
the world it's a pleasure to
be here with you and I'm I'm
delighted to be able to report
that here in San Francisco
and other ports in but a good
day and to the south of crab
fishermen have been able to
bring thousands of pounds of
Dungeness crab safe to help
the local crab to market --
it is not the case of north
we are continuing to see --
the delays in the season due
to the stabilization and --
an uncertain climate driven
by -- factors that we are
certain about those factors
include global climate change
-- global warming brought about
by fossil fuel -- emissions to
the atmosphere in there impacts
to the ocean -- the scientific
causal connection between those
impacts and the impacts to our
fishery into our members --
is clear -- I want to thank
you Mister chairman for your
leadership in this process
three leadership on Senate
bills thirteen oh nine thirteen
ten -- to our friends at the
department of fish and wildlife
to the governor for advancing
the request for commercial
fishery disaster assistance to
the secretary of commerce in
two thousand sixteen as we all
know that fishery disaster was
declared in January of twenty
seventeen appropriations were
made by Congress in February
of this year twenty eighteen
-- and we have been working
with the department to put
together a spend plan that will
be equitable -- and we believe
forward looking and forward
thinking in its approach
to advancing approaches the
mitigation in this fishery
-- which we know that we
desperately need -- but we
also need financial support for
our hard working members the
sweet I want to thank them for
maintaining -- and an upper to
-- an optimistic outlook in the
face of devastating challenges
-- in the face of severe
financial hardship and in the
face of knowing that this is
our new normal that commercial
fisheries in the state of
California particularly
for station fisheries crab
fisheries are going to be
facing the mower gas it
challenges -- in every single
season -- that we are are
going to try to -- -- whether
it be here in San Francisco
Bay or to the north or in
states to the north -- we know
that this is our new normal
and that is why two weeks ago
the Pacific coast federation
of fishermen's associations
filed a lawsuit in California
District Court against thirty
fossil fuel industry companies
for their role in producing
this situation for knowingly
continuously -- promoting
their industry and the and
the products that they sell
to a and the damage that it
is because to a commercial
fisherman and to the coastal
communities of the state of
California and the state of
Oregon these companies very
the truth about the impacts
that climate change will have
to the oceans to society as we
know it and two in particular
commercial crap fisheries
so we will be holding them
accountable and we look forward
to seeing them in court in
the meantime we're delighted
that certain parts of the
state have dodged a bullet
this year and that we are able
to prosecute this fishery but
delays continue -- commercial
fishery disaster assistance
is coming and we're grateful
to our friends in the federal
government and the California
congressional delegation for
moving that forward -- and
I just want to provide one
comment on the continuing
crisis -- the the political
crisis -- and the solutions
that we are coming up with
relating to wailing tango in
this fishery I do what I want
to say that I am pleased to
see that California is going
first and stepping up to the
plate because when the federal
process prevails fishermen
come last I firmly believe
that the well working group is
maintaining the fleets ability
to be in the driver's seat and
to be complete and total equal
participants in this process
our voice matters and it's
being heard our colleagues in
the state of California are
listening and you're gonna hear
from some of the members of
the working group later today
and public comment -- and on a
panel later -- about the work
that they're doing tireless
hours of their lives to solving
this problem the fishermen
do not want to see wells
entangled and we are going to
be -- strong partners in the
process to address this problem
head on so with that I will
be glued in thank you so much
for the opportunity to give Mr
outlined and the drop in on you
do appreciate all three of you
gentlemen for being here today
we think we are open up for
questions or comments from the
committee Mister vice chair Q.
so question to the agencies
mention resource I think this
committee has a interest in
your success and making sure
that the state is providing
appropriate resources to
address the issues that that
we are fine and to become the
budget question it is going
to be you have the ability to
interviews but I just change
composer process we of course
have the ability and whatever
I put pressure this point on
our budgetary because I think
this is something that this
committee and the budget sub
committees need to be looking
at but I would think it would
be appropriate if we could
get the help of the agencies
to support your working with
apartment finance as well
as our essential ability
to make I request influence
budget to ensure that you have
appropriate resources and this
is even a bigger question that
double Cassidy because water
quality testing is something
that has been given a short
shrift in budget conversations
in the past in the past number
of years and yet if we're
really going to create the
basis for addressing changes
in chemistry the oceans more
toxins as they come in from on
shore are shorter developing
water quality testing as well
as testing the product that
the state's responsible for
through part of public health
and through that for many
fish wildlife really becomes
credit so I'm hoping that we
can work with your agencies
and they you're making proper
requests that at war that
working with this committee
that this committee could put
together a package to look at
how we make requests within our
budget cycles to ensure that
you have the right resources
without putting you on the spot
it would be great to get to be
able to work with you over the
next couple of months and make
sure that we're asking and that
you're asking for appropriate
resources that we can back that
up so that we get the testing
done as it needs to be done I
think that's one of the things
that we can do for the industry
is ensure that that testing
is happening appropriately
smoothly and is adequately
Joe like to comment on that
what would come and I'd really
going to put you on the spot
you have really should the
department of finance and don't
miss you want to do that but
if you can help with either now
or in the future on what we're
talking about the way resources
the scope of what we'd be
happy to ask for that and how
we navigate the politics of
administrations process in
asking for its budget as well
as the legislative that's it
would be easier for us here
but -- let's say that that
getting too detailed I'd say
we welcome the opportunity
to work with the incoming
administration to advance
that every part that offer
that request right thank you
I to be a I would say that we
service here the same use the
echo the comments -- that we
welcome the opportunity compare
bad band with the resources
we have we do the best we
can and I would hope that the
legislative budget process
as well as the administration
with respect requests coming
out of this committee so is
the chair but the is good I
can work on that a work with
the committee on what adequate
resource pack I guess the right
-- it was a couple years back
-- where I think there was some
frustration and -- there was
about finding that was advanced
both for fish and wildlife AD
PH -- in we actually saw --
-- department public health
funding card out -- and Avalon
asked the department public
health to come in on that today
-- but I will share with you
that is incredibly frustrating
because you -- have what are
moving together are más on
the and really the ones that
are doing the work for you
see a lot of the funding that
is needed is an apartment
public health side Britain's
the testing so I think you're
absolutely right on in the for
the working with vice chair and
to this committee on a fancy
that I know that -- similar
ting was all over that as well
and make sure that we're able
to see that but again we will
get into -- past years looking
forward out we actually need
to ensure that our public
health has that plan as is
-- fish wildlife yesterday
the consider aye aye what is
get a better understanding of
I heard a lot about testing
and what the scores are not
significant amount what we can
do to reverse the situation
I mean I know part of it is
the environment easy to cast
fingers and other people
what can we do as a state
to better try to mitigate
the situation in hearing
-- is to take that I'd love
to respond to that question
the California judges crab
fishery needs to be managed
to become more resilient in
the face of what we know will
be our new climate feature
which is currently what we're
seeing today and what we saw
in twenty fifteen and that's a
buzz word managing for me what
does that really mean what we
know that commercial fishing
businesses need to be stable
they are subjected to a new
form of a risk that they were
not before other industries
manage their risks far better
than we do in California --
in commercial fisheries --
we do not have any sort of
financial mechanism or capital
facilities to be able to insure
commercial fisheries in times
of struggle a hardship -- make
ends meet pay the bills when
boats are tied down we need
to develop the financial tools
to be able to address this
to let our fishing businesses
be resilient to the financial
risks of of closure and delay
we also need to be able to
address the more gas it head on
we need to know more of -- when
it's coming we need to develop
the predictive tools that can
enable fishermen and agencies
to be able to determine
what business and management
decisions they need to make
ahead of the season otherwise
there are lost in the dark or
we have impacts that are far
less predictable and therefore
far more damaging than what we
would otherwise encounter and
then I believe that we need
to develop tools that can deal
with them all gas and there
are certain approaches that
could potentially be used --
decoration or the holding of
crabs that are known to be
toxic until the talks and can
be cleared out is one solution
another would be developing
sensors or other devices
that can more easily detect
demo gases -- that technology
currently exists but hasn't
been implemented in this
way and that's why I think
-- are are technologically
advanced society and in the
bay area here in San Francisco
particular can be helpful
there -- and I'll just make
the the point here that these
are all very expensive proposed
requiring a whole bunch of
capital on a lot of investment
who's going to pay for the --
is it going to be the fishing
industry -- we we've already
described the financial
hardship we're dealing with is
going to the taxpayer certainly
the public owns the resource
and has an interest in bringing
an end but organization
believes that the company is
the fossil fuel industry is
the one that should be held
accountable care and that's
the nature of the lawsuit
that I mentioned earlier
and I'm not allowed it is
as best robin I pointed out
as with most things climate
change right now it's adapting
to it not tried to prevent it
and I don't see this anytime
soon being able to prevent to
mark asset outbreaks in our
waters that the scale is too
big the sciences is not as
well understood -- but we can
do a better job understand
the biological pathways what
conditions in the to the
production of the toxins our
those toxins working their way
through the food chain once
we understand that we may be
able to move to prevention --
I will note that -- of that
ten percent of the disaster
from that set to mitigation
that's about two point five
million a much of that money
will go towards our indie
to try to answer some of
these questions and that's
really what that competitive
grant process is set up to
do is to try to figure out
how we can best adapt to it
from the department's
perspective -- see page
public health perspective
one at that our role is to
Medicaid our findings the
results so they can be used
from the data can be used to
have some kind of prevention
strategies are usually use
for future -- -- thinking
so besides the rise in
temperature notions or
any other thoughts about
what else is driving this
imbalance in the system --
we know that ocean
acidification is also a
confounding factor it's a
it it's likely that lower PH
results in greater expression
of demo like acid in the
algal species that produce it
sit in the chair -- further
exacerbating this problem of
course lower PH and warming
temperatures are correlated
-- in addition the the large
scale oceanographic phenomenon
like the blog -- that we
saw in general -- with just
less up Welling therefore
water being delivered to the
shelf because system is also
I also just want
clear fire just make make sure
-- you you mentioned a number
of -- potential ideas in terms
of medication things at nine
six situation what I would
really -- saying is it's very
difficult to move forward with
anything on a large scale in
many the reason you mention
without with enter standing
problems so tell we really
have a better understanding
of what the problem is and
whether it can be manage --
locally and it's very difficult
to say or to justify any
sort of large expenditures
yeah I'd be delighted to
commented that if -- if I
may um without question we we
do know what the fleet knows
what the problem is it's the
inability to go fishing for
our members and our business
that is the problem and when we
focus on the immediate annual
scale measures that need to
be taken in order to address
this -- I believe that we do
have some of the solutions
and we know precisely what
we need to do from the agency
perspective -- agree with with
doctor she meant that we will
likely not be able to take
action that will prevent the
trajectory that we are on --
we need to acknowledge that
we need to rather than trying
to throw money at problems we
can't solve the immediate in
terms of preventing warming of
the oceans -- in in our budget
process we need to take action
that's going to ensure that
businesses can continue to
operate and did to do the kinds
of research which I believe we
can do in order to build those
predictive tools that I spoke
thank you so much interest
in just one last comment I
think that it too is we're
talking about finding you
know just make this comment
that -- this year we're going
beyond the guts of this rare
-- in we're actually there's
was some concern that we're
seeing -- impact on me I is
one of the high test up north
I think -- that's an item that
we're gonna want to be able
to discuss how we can have to
be a ticket we're gonna need
to move into more advanced
manner find testing -- as were
seen that one hundred tax I
know it was isolated but --
if that's going to mean any
different procedures within
the department not asking
you to comment on issues of
budget but does that mean
anything different on your
folks on the ground when
it comes to -- individuals
in the lab and testing
additional time to make
separate to route tested meet
samples of a you know it it
obviously you know were I can
you know we're doing the best
we can with the resources we
have to do additional testing
-- -- when we're running these
tional tests be it we've been
primarily worried about the
guts with that's where -- the
higher acid levels to be if you
will store and what we had this
year is it when you're on the
gods and in the me correct --
in just wondering if we see the
and again I want to be clear
that was an isolated test sheer
-- what is that going to mean
additional time for your folks
on the ground in the lab just
wondering about what that looks
like for you obviously you're
gonna run additional testing
or to me -- yeah it's gonna
require additional time and
resource to run those analyses
that's great she will follow up
off line -- là should mean just
have an additional compensation
-- as we move forward here
January sourcing thank you
so much but before we adjourn
this panel would like to be to
see if we have any additional
comments from committee Mister
to this vice chair right
German thank you so much we're
very grateful for your time
you know we'll see here just
a little bit you know would
like to be able to open up
our public coming in the first
portion of public comment what
a second after a two nine six
any individual can can speak
with the committee I welcome
to be a step up to the spike
you have two minutes anyone
on a on the first two panels
welcome any public comment
green sea no public comment
we're not gonna be bringing
it back to committee together
bring up our next panel is
six panels can be focusing on
whale entangled in ship strikes
how we're gonna be hearing a
briefing and well taken efforts
as well ship strike concerns we
could please have the following
step fort Scott been seen as a
research fisheries biologists
the southwest sign center with
no fisheries we're grateful
that beautiful consists here he
is the guy on the ground for no
up -- in he's a marine mammal
health extremely response
program manager were also great
for the cut rock what is here
he's a senior marine ecologist
four point blue conservation
science Mister Benson is gonna
be focusing on the technical
aspects of the entanglements
in no was collaborative support
of the working group efforts
on a and he's gonna be going
through the date out looking at
the numbers the tiny locations
train six said Rep Peter
Peter is the person who is
on the ground or if you will
-- in the C. I. A.
and he's gonna be given this --
an update about what he's seen
out there when they're focusing
on entanglement and we're
grateful that cut rock what is
here and he's going to prison
in the research which shows
that management efforts to be
able to guide ship trafficking
decrease overlap of whales and
fisheries could decrease deaths
-- from strikes in entanglement
significantly if there is a
coordinated effort and that
simply is not happening at
the moment we're going to be
de do a deeper dive on this
issue later in two thousand
nineteen so without further
ado we're not gonna be turned
over to Mister Benson with no
a fisheries to be able to give
us the data with well taken
circular five minutes once he
thank you for all the work it
it's been a busy unfortunately
a busy few years -- you the
floor is yours at thank you
very much for the sovereignty
share the status with you I
want to make it clear however
that -- I -- imprisoning
this on behalf of Dan Lawson
in Lawrence signs with the
west coast region office --
and Scott Benson and I lied
leatherback turtle research
here in that California's
west coast the state marine
reptile -- and so happy to
do this on behalf of Wharton
fan of next slide please
I can we can do for you if you
see next light that's perfect
thank you got it okay excellent
all right I'm in payment of
marine mammals in fishing gear
is a global problem as you
probably -- also where on the
east coast -- where in payment
of -- north Atlantic right
whales is a major concern for
that population -- our agency
Nazarian fisheries services at
unified large well in payment
fishing here long the US
west coast as a primary prime
priority management issue --
these entertainment reports
are up opportunistic and
clearly in under estimate of
total and hang -- many factors
contribute to integument
reports being under estimate
and has to be found by somebody
other person needs know how
report that -- there've been
four hundred fifty wailing
payments reporting California
since nineteen eighty two --
and as you mentioned earlier
there's been a recent spike
in entanglements hundred
seventy seven reports during
two thousand fourteen to two
thousand seventeen and that's
actually forty percent of
all contain reports since
nineteen eighty two so as you
mentioned before a relatively
recent -- concern in terms
of make getting people's
attention next slide please
this is the long term -- --
data for this -- as you can
see here that a averaged
about ten and ting once a year
until the late two thousands
and then jumped up to thirty
three on average during two
thousand fourteen two thousand
sixteen the majority the
reports do originate from
California all the wells
roles reporters and tangled in
Oregon Washington again this
is for the west coast region
-- organ California wash --
or in California Washington
and -- in two thousand
seventeen there was twenty
six confirmed entanglements
thirty six reported and in
two thousand eighteen were
actually above that number
with twenty seven reported
and thirty six -- -- to exceed
the twenty seven confirmed
in thirty six reported the
higher number this year is
apparently trivial to -- a
greater -- number of anything
what's coming from Washington
state next slide please
the humpback whales and gray
whales on the most commonly
reported species in this is
an important point here is
that in California we have a
-- we call a -- est a stock
here and that California
Oregon Washington stop with
that stock is comprised of two
different we not known as a
distinct population segments
so this is a in this case we
have an endangered Central
America -- DPS any threatened
Mexico DPS the be in danger
Central America -- GPS as is
a smaller number and so that
it's important to know that the
fees -- but no recognizes the
to DPS is even though we had
they are also recognized under
the marine mammal protection
act as a stock I hope that's
clear to everyone -- gray
whales are also -- entangled in
this -- in these in fisheries
here -- at that population has
been stable since the nineteen
nineties -- humpback whales
have been increasing -- the
blue whale population eastern
north Pacific is stable and the
fan will stock off California
or Oregon Washington is also
increasing these of the species
that are primarily involved
in ten next slide please
this is the summary for two
thousand eighteen twenty seven
confirmed -- humpback whales
again -- you know are the
majority of the entanglements
-- you've got numbers for
gray well six we will one
unconfirmed in well one on
one confirmed one ident on
identified -- day most of the
payments are involved with that
dodges crab fishery part that's
because we know this because
that fisheries marked -- well
with other traps or mark well
and -- I'm also a volunteer
on the local discontentment
network and so when we have a
says successful disentangle we
can retrieve that indeterminate
least in cases of -- Duchess
crab -- if that was actually
the fishery that was involved
but other fish fish excuse
me other fix your fisheries
that have had inhaled whales
include -- spot Peron -- that's
humpbacks sable fish long line
humpback gill net gray whale
and hump back -- stripe shrimp
spiny lobster also both compact
although dungeons crab is most
often -- identified expertise
in about two minutes Sir thank
you this is a locator issue
shows locations where the most
and the tech and hang which
have been encountered or have
been reported it's important to
note here that the places that
are highest are areas where
much more people on the water
-- southern California Monterey
Bay less so in some of the
more outer coast areas -- the
next next number okay this is
just for Dungeness crab alone
and in this case here we're
looking at a by month -- you'll
see that there are greater
number reports during spring
and early summer it means that
could be attributable to the
fact that that's when humpback
whales here it could also be
attributable to that's the time
when more people on the water
and at sea conditions are more
favorable to see these things
-- only five the forty records
were before two thousand
thirteen said ninety percent
reported since two thousand
thirteen again that coincides
with the marking of the gear
that's fine next what we don't
know -- here in tango and get
a fining integument origins --
so where to focus management
and research efforts --
understanding configurations of
the gear involved knowing the
number of entanglements that
occur we know for sure that's
an underestimate under S.
understanding how we'll
behavior in gear can lead
to in in in payment once an
interaction starts and then
long term understanding the
outcomes of these entanglements
at the animal is going to
be able to survive or in
reproduced as normally or if
it has been compromised as
a consequence of the intake
interaction that's all I have
thank you thank you very much
Sir will be opening up coming
to the committee in just a
moment we're grateful that
Peter focuses here he is the
chairman of the ground --
representing our marine mammal
health industry in response
program he's gonna tell us
what he's been seen out in the
ocean conditions as well Sir
we welcome will give you a five
minutes thank you for being
here thank you for inviting
me I will say that -- I have
several of my to some tangling
team with me here today --
several behind me for Scott
right here you might is asking
to stand up for a second so
we can now recognize simply
guys that are on the network
the latest stand up if you're
part of the team's having give
you around of applying right
thank you for being here
yeah thank you so much for
for inviting me have an hour
presentation you give me five
minutes all poll jump through
this to make it happen I want
to make it very clear that --
the complexity on how wells
becoming tangled is much more
complex than most people have
considered and on the other
side getting them disentangled
is not as simple as yelling
Sam Sam jump on the will cut
the line and so I'll take
yours going after transferring
area of primary speech is
involved as Scott mentioned
we are humpback whale in the
gray well it's interesting
that ten years ago the gray
whales were more calm than
the humpbacks -- and that has
switched recently and -- other
species of concern of the blue
whale simply because they're
so large I worked on two blue
whales and they're impossible
to disentangle from the water
is there to get their tests
so big and powerful Ryan can
attest to that -- north Pacific
right well we haven't had any
of those entangled legally but
as that -- species recovers
if we get entangled right
well on our coast is gonna
be a game changer -- other
species known fan well killer
whale meat you will create
is and -- sperm whales oops
because back up there are a
number of different types of
entanglements -- suggested to
you've gone
Carillo some for some reasons
jumping off in every type
seven tango one we have a a
-- -- about the head which
usually includes the mouth and
-- in damages the bailing of
particular concern is when the
math entanglement drops back
to -- the back of the mouth
so we have the head -- we have
an appendage Gaines inventor
please well we need to bring
the flippers advance -- threat
cake -- lumbar region which is
a large body entanglement other
peduncle and which is the tale
technically flukes and the --
compound complex entanglement
in this particular animal
it got involved with fifteen
sets of here and twelve Travis
and each one of the steps and
involve the mouth a flipper
the flu and most of the body
and we completely disentangled
sort of free this is what -- if
Jackson Pollock was a fisherman
what his gear would look like
-- it's important to note that
-- intending materials are much
more diverse than simply --
-- dentures crab gear -- some
of the most common stuff they
were seeing out there is from
police blue steel rope -- the
three stranded -- which is very
common in the ground fisheries
also the monofilament long
line which is the action on the
animal tends to be a like a --
cheese cutting knife you can
cut into the barber very easily
also mention on three strand
district three strand rope
tends to be very abrasive and
can -- can kind of cut through
like sandpaper and -- looks
if you go back up there --
the -- -- gill nets or another
-- -- issue a monofilament
going out -- that tend to be
completely engrossing the well
and the -- -- -- keep going
guys the same net -- which are
-- nylon material they tend to
-- -- the oil can to be able
to blow through the same nasco
one more and -- but they carry
a lot of the -- gear on them
as it was cut into the body
and then we have the other
-- that's another saying that
which completely in in gross
the -- the recent don't and
-- since we're talking about
aquaculture here we have a
great will that got entangled
in and aquaculture frame and
we stir frame and we had no
idea how to deal with this
animal -- we've also had --
just anchor chains -- of world
getting tangled in encryption
the injuries caused by
entanglement are are quite
varied and they range from
irritations Chiu -- death --
abrasion and chafing -- is
very uncomfortable for the
animal we assume -- but is
generally not life threatening
-- we do see it quite a bit of
physical defamation of a funny
appendages in other parts of of
the body this can affect their
ability to feed officially
and -- -- sometimes these
defamation jerk or certainly --
permanent -- we get amputations
of the -- flute blades this
is more catastrophic to hump
back because they -- the power
into their food -- and the --
-- the entertainment can cause
a complete application of the
-- of the flukes as you see
here with this great well we
also get the -- here here's
one in which -- we got the flu
but not the rest of the well
-- we also have appendages
that are -- amputated this
occurs both in gray whales
and humpbacks this usually
occurs when a line cinches
around the appendage and then
it -- starts to group to grade
and cuts off circulation and
then it instantly falls off
others also nutritional stress
this is one of my greatest
concerns simply because it
-- it -- demonstrates an
immense amount of suffering
that the animals going through
-- -- for an animal get into
this condition it takes --
probably a month or two --
cam like this and it's all
a period of of fear and
stress we also get infection
an infestation of this is
a gill net on agree well --
restricted disability to move
and feed and and the likes
to go over then we also have
a direct effect of drowning
the animal on on the net
-- there's a bunch of
contributing factors is much
more complex than simply a
well encountering the -- of the
fishing gear a lot of it has
to do with the well behavior
a you can see right here that
this impact is on its side this
in normal feeding posture for
a humpback whale and you can
see the -- crap you're in the
background and so when the line
is vertical and in the water
and will speeding on its side
where there's a high density of
-- crab traps it gets into the
mouth of the well for easily
and what happens is that line
migrates to the back of the
mouth and then starts to cut
through the webbing in the
back of the mouth is is if you
took dental floss and you took
your mouth back here years and
and that -- diminishes the the
efficiency of feeding -- they
get to click it again to make
this video role others also
the well behavior that they
they love to twist and turn
him by looking at some of the
underwater behavior the and we
can kind of see how they get
wrapped up in loose line in the
water this doesn't happen as
much of the line is tight this
loose in the water you can get
pretty severe others also the
rogue behavior something that
-- -- line of investigation
we're going down with the help
of some of the people in this
room electric Aug and -- John
mail or and and Jim Anderson
is trying to understand what
it is about -- this line if you
look at this there's a number
of loops -- splices knocks and
float that all contributed to
the complexity of the intent
of meant that twisted that
then became very severe and so
we're looking down -- ways to
simplify the rogue behavior so
that -- the way -- will will be
less likely to become entangled
pointing counters the line
and I think this is a very --
-- beneficial line of thought
to go down effect okay that's
actually good -- to back it
up please I just gonna say are
responding to large one tangle
Mrs is a very large team effort
-- we have for organizations
in addition to the five --
stranding network members --
that all participate -- in this
-- it starts with very good
information -- such as the --
response cards -- a number of
years ago just before you saw a
big spike in report is we self
published something that I've
I've shared with everybody --
to help educate the public on
what to do to -- get as good
information so we can -- get
out there and -- and affected
just entanglement a number
of factors are considered in
advance of actually doing to
disentangle men and they're
all listed here I could talk
for an hour on everyone of
those but essentially it's is
not simply a reaction is that
we consider lots of different
-- aspects all to -- reduce
suffering in the well and
Max my safety for the respond
-- so -- once we launch an
entangled will response we have
these other things that we go
through we have a process from
of the analysis to evaluating
the demeanor of the whale
trying to figure out how long
entanglement spent on the
likelihood of success -- we we
need to hit it to get the --
video going what back it up
but one of the things we try
to do I think if you click it
digital video overall we tried
but never on -- what this does
is -- when I'm trying to show
here is that we try to reduce
the system so that all we
have to do is one cut and if
this video role that you would
see us actually -- a Houston
right to just cut once that's
right memory better -- so
it's going to invest the next
one of our biggest concerns
is it didn't mean or the well
-- I'd I can say that on very
rare occasions just the well
actually understand why were
there and so we get situations
like this if you look in the
uppermost on the left there's
little silvery object that's
are cutting tool and this
represents away all that that
-- Beatriz looks three times a
and -- -- trying to get out of
the intent of an after Kerr we
have a bunch of custom tools
that we work with and -- most
of them are designed -- by our
members -- for various purposes
and approaches we are telling
the truth on the far right
cutting tools in the middle
-- one of our secondary goals
is retrieving the gear -- this
was -- that animal a crescent
city that had -- fifteen sets
and twelve traps in each set
we retrieve all of the gear
we don't want to leave any
crap in the water and so my
team works very diligently to
retrieve all of the venture
with some water we don't want
ghost gear we don't want to
-- plastics in the ocean we're
also developing responding
partners on the California
department of fish and wildlife
to will become a part of this
with their boats like -- marlin
and some near the books they
have Coast Guard we need to
get some training together to
get them up the last couple
of years they responded really
really well I've asked for a --
twenty foot -- rapid response
the they gave me a -- cutter
the last time so they're being
very involved -- the network is
several needs not the least of
which is reimbursable response
costs and I will say that in
the -- on the bass fishing
fisheries bill of right now
-- large well disentangle is
not specified as a line item
-- -- in tangled see lines and
turtles is but -- large well
response is not -- we have new
tools we want to develop -- I
think -- California department
fishing game needs to have its
in the show on this outreach
material -- we need training
and cross training -- monks
not only all the network
members but -- but also the
government agencies and I'll
I'll mention very quickly at
the bottom -- we need support
for research for understanding
how the becoming tangled and I
also mentioned DS W.
DSW disaster service worker
of thing it's a program in
the state already at present
none of our respond or is
have any sort of insurance for
doing something is stream we
dangerous and I was on the --
-- the paradise -- Sarmatian
over the last few weeks and
all of us were covered by
the state program called DSW
and something I would like
to see is that the large well
-- integument responders can
be covered under the disaster
service workers -- workmen's
compensation is essentially
what it is for and and I think
that will help only qualified
responders to get out there
and do it rather than having
people that figure that they
can have a quick path to get
on the Ellen DeGeneres show
by jumping on a will so we're
gonna be conclude here pretty
quick that's my last one eighty
two so we want to say thank
you for all of your work were
very very grateful that we have
questions but what do a right
after we hear from current
rock which is a senior Marino
ecologists with point look
conservation service we've
heard about -- not only the
extreme challenges but just as
disturbing images and why it is
so -- that we act together to
be able to protect California's
majestic well population here
and we have another challenge a
and nowadays ship strikes with
large commercial vessels cut
is going to be doing our first
dive into this issue we're
going to do a deeper dive later
this year the bill to give you
Creek preview we're grateful
Mister rock with a service
record your five minutes
we're gonna be here might
just make sure it's green and
you have a pull that up if
you don't mind is beautiful
working for good all right
thank you guys for inviting
-- as the senator mentioned
earlier entanglements are
important issue this is a
meeting about sustainability
fishery conservation of whales
but -- this in ten minutes she
doesn't happen in isolation
ship strikes are part of the
bigger picture so I've been
tasked with giving you a little
bit of that broader perspective
so at point blue one of the
things that we do work on is
trying to understand the ship
strikes issue as long as well
as -- working on entanglements
it'll give you a little bit
of a brief presentation at the
end -- but my research focuses
on -- decreasing well gas from
collisions with ships and we
publish some work last year
that it was intended to --
filled what it's been a long
standing gap in understand a
and died and understand the
numbers of whales that are
being killed by ships out in
our oceans on the west coast --
to do that we used calculations
based on what is -- originally
enabling counter model train
understand how often two ships
come in contact with each other
we did that instead for ships
and rails -- and were able to
then estimate the number of
deaths for humpbacks fin whales
and blue whales along the west
coast are we could not do that
for gray well because we do not
have the underlying data to do
so -- and when we look at the
results of those -- ladies what
we find is that it is likely
that more than eighty whales in
total among those three species
are struck by ships each year
are within the whole west coast
federal waters and so or blue
as a number of different for
the different species for we
will fax eighteen per year
humpback whales are twenty two
and fin whales forty three and
that means that for blue else
that's about eight times and
for how back about twice the
federal guidelines that suggest
that set the number of human
because mortalities that should
occur from all combined sources
and not just ships right so
we're getting a lot of death
beyond just -- the net or from
ship strikes back go beyond
that -- acceptable number
if we look a little bit more
closely on the distribution
this is representing the top
ten percent of -- mortality
estimates and you can see
that the those high -- high
risk areas are concentrated
off because California
particularly central California
and southern California --
but the good news is that we
can -- address a lot about
seventy four percent of the
blue whale eighty two percent
a humpback whale and sixty
five percent of been whale
deaths by looking specifically
at these regions so we don't
have to think about the whole
-- coast coastal waters we
can look at a smaller area
-- there are proven solutions
and the main ones that have
been really tested and and
and shown to have success had
been done on the east coast
for for blank right whales and
those are speed restrictions
and the traffic routing to
avoid rail hot spot so knowing
where the wheels congregate
-- and as best possible
providing ship shipping
routes that avoid those --
those areas there are other
potential solutions that are
being explored but these are
explored but these are really
the only current solutions
that we have and they they
happen to be successful
so just to put that in
perspective you can see our
estimates force ship strike
mortality there on the left
for each of the species and
that's compared to the annual
estimates from no -- for
entanglements which are for
hunt backs fourteen per year
about one blue whale per year
on these are for the lack of
average for the last five years
and a half of an where -- and
so you you get the sense that
for humpbacks these two sources
-- -- death a human because
that are about on the same
level but for blue whales and
fin whales ship strikes are
actually much greater issue
than entanglement although
again with caution the wells --
we're just recently first found
to be entangled in last year so
that may be an emerging issue
so also just a quickly give
you a little bit of preliminary
work to be done on the
entitlement -- issues directly
-- we have been taking data
with -- right without see
-- cruises shipboard cruises
on both whales and crap part
densities -- for a number of
years and since two thousand
and eight we've been -- we've
been counting the the crap
parts that we see in the
water so with some preliminary
analyses we've actually put
together some models about
the distribution of crap parts
which are hard to -- to get
that information and so this
is kind of a an initial --
asks Atty understanding where
are and and the temporal --
changes that occur -- through
time and and and for the
years that we have done those
analyses from two thousand
and eight to two thousand and
seventeen we can break those up
into sort for years which are
warmer water years and cooler
years and find that in the
warmer water years but appear
to be construed close to the
shore and at higher densities
than in the cooler years and
that is particularly during
may of those years -- because
that's when we have data for
so that is of interest in
understanding how co occurrence
between whales and crab pot
-- plays out and if we look
at combining our models for
this regional sales and the
distribution of crap parts
we see that in general -- on
the left those two are the
observed entanglements and the
predicted model results of a
co occurrence between wells and
car parts and in general those
preliminary models show --
that the that is capturing that
-- increasing trend in recent
years -- with improvements we
can probably get better and
we also see that -- occurrence
of these maps here show co
current and is also stronger in
those and former -- water for
years and closer into shore so
we're looking at -- potentially
some of the causes for this
recent spike in entertainment
and that's all I have for
now so if you have any
questions the switches
record when we open it up
to the comedian seat by Chad
any questions or comments
one thing that's been part
of the discussion and looking
this is probably a question
for even some of the other
panels but we've identified
will entanglements where
there observer and we've been
trying to get here labels are
we able to identify or track
back to where the table that's
happened with any certainty
or are we really just looking
at where we observe it and
try and rescue that way out
there and so because if we can
build a correlation of there's
more that we need to do to to
better understand where the
tanks are actually happening
not just where there observe
because that could be quite
some distance in quite some
time it's up with something we
do on a regular basis is that
the fisheries tags as soon as
we know that there's a fishery
on their -- we notify Lauren
and Justin was Becky down it
nor purity and they contact
the fishermen to see if they
want to come out and help us
retrieve their gear and so
we're able to get information
on where the gear was set how
long it has been since the
will shows up with and tangled
and and so we can do that for
the dungeon is crap we can't
do it for the other fishery
where we were there's no que
and something that's going no
I don't think I've level to
add but you're exactly correct
to do it mean the tags do help
do that and we would be great
if other types of fisheries
also had similar types of
tags we did it again do that
kind of investigative work as
you mentioned it just because
the word cited does not mean
that's where they entanglement
encourage and these animals
can carry this gear around for
weeks to months a year several
months -- which confounds thing
so -- as Peter mentioned folks
are working on that part of it
-- trying to assemble enough
for that data together from
the disentangle months we've
had but it'll it'll take some
time that the the data we don't
have that much data yet because
there are things it seems to be
key to all of this is is real
data and be able to collect
the data and reliable data
of not just where the wealthy
take a well with a counter but
but we're eating county year
to better understand some of
those patterns and relations
and we are getting cooperation
with the organ fisheries --
the most recent disentangle
when I did was with an organ
tagged with brought down to
-- -- -- Monterey Bay from
Oregon because I can understand
why they're identified in the
Monterey Bay with the about a
well watching and both center
out there they can see them
more often last further up
the coast but that's not where
they're being taken okay if we
can better build relationships
with our neighbors to the
north and figure out how we
can get more types of fisheries
indicated at least figure out
where they are coming from
but I would think help without
in that there's another issue
in that regard that we're
starting year as how long does
it take for a certain level
of -- injury to happen on the
way I'll so in other words
we may find a entertainment
that was actually encountered
a month possibly two months
earlier which which and then
kind of changes your monthly
distribution of the commonality
of -- of entanglements and so
if if he throws a little bit
of a monkey wrench into having
a real fine data set but --
if we can identify different
animals been injured for six
weeks the and it came down from
Oregon we know that it doesn't
impact the California --
dungeons crab fishery in terms
of a statistic of an entangled
so better job with research
and that's again I think an
appropriate role for the state
is to figure out how we can
facilitate with some of that
research but then also working
with the industries that
bigger better able to identify
which here where and and how
that moves as we understand
what the well to some
thank you
thank you so much was vice
chair just a few questions and
building upon -- the vice chair
what would you say when you
come across a well it's been
a table and I know that some
this is guessing are you
thinking that that will have
been integral for weeks -- in
this is made ongoing problem
maturity rainy season what
do you all see on the ground
or what is your guide -- from
taking a look at -- majority
of cases week we've seen
-- an animal in which the
entanglement was observer and
our response was six hours
later we also have a situation
where we know one animal was
entangled on October first and
was disentangled on October
twenty eight and so we have a
sense of the level of damage
-- it in general we don't
see the entanglements and
tell their on for at least
a week or so -- but when we
start to see -- diminish tell
they've been on for three
three to six weeks has the
public become more aware
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
the public has become more
aware and as you know well
watching is a growth industry
-- and a lot more people in
the water and that they are
also becoming more aware on
how to report these things
we can add one other dot
quick note that -- when this
was published it was first
distributed Monterey and as
soon as this was distributed
the number of reports of
intangible wealth went up by
an order of magnitude to talk
about the -- in the numbers the
numbers and going down since
the peak year two thousand
fifteen connecting to your --
the city sixty shows why should
check seventy two just a bit
but Chiu believe it's because
of the efforts that's been
happening in regards to please
originally came to us and
said we needed to be a to do
something about it which I've
never seen industry do before
right say if we don't fix this
we will be around right now and
we have to be able to -- come
up with some long term solution
since then we've seen that --
decreasing entanglements I'd
like to go to get that what
you're seeing on the ground if
you believe that the efforts
that have been happening here
in the state have been working
I think the information you're
gonna get from -- Jerod a
little later on that his study
of of the ocean cycles and
climb in the ocean I think
is a stronger -- influence of
the incidence of entanglements
-- rather than anything that
we are actively doing I mean
we're essentially farm and
we go out there and put out
the fire but -- proactively
though so you you think I I
get it so you when you say
that they can two thousand
fifteen we saw the blob and
it was very warm in the ocean
-- airplane traps where --
the creel in angel beats for
-- all that that's why we saw
the increase in because we've
seen a cooler ocean since two
thousand fifteen that's why
we seen a decrease in in in
in the big influence I believe
is that year when they had
the big delay yeah there was
what -- Jim Anderson says was
a derby mentality for there's
an immense amount of gear that
was put in got it and a lot of
people from out of state put in
-- nine hundred feline in two
hundred feet of water and bingo
tell -- cam it's kind of I can
speak to that a little bit to
get go head -- so a couple of
things we can only address may
because that's the only time
we have data for those a little
bit later in the season but
-- what we did find I didn't
show it in our preliminary
models is that that that year
when there was the delayed
opening of the fishery there
was definitely a lot more guilt
here still in the water in may
and further out offshore so
that's clearly and issues the
that sort of the development
of the fishery three times
after opening -- those parts
tend to move off shore as the
inshore waters get fished out
-- and that's where the whales
tend to be occurring the other
thing that we found with some
of our data is that whales
are actually a lot of writing
earlier to the area and so that
means that there's more overlap
tempore early with the fishery
I'd like to switch gears to --
fisheries that well spaceship
strikes by the name when the
concern that we have is no
formal tracking the number
you put up on the screen were
eighty whales -- in total -- I
would have been guessing here
that that's a fraction of what
we see talk to us about how
you came up with the eighty --
because one of the items that
we are talking about prior to
this hearing is there is no
formal track in the last in
the majors sees it or to self
report I don't think there's a
whole lot of self reports out
there correct -- in so in the
other question I have is why
so many fin whales what what
is that -- with the dynamic
that you seen yeah -- so there
the formal tracking is is
not too dissimilar from the
entanglement so but of course
you don't see whales struck
very often they do come into
court on the thousand ships so
that's the that's the analogy
there -- and then of course
there's the whale carcasses
that washed up on shore and a
necropsy shows that there was
one for strong so those are
the two sources of -- definite
their debts -- number so we
can find it so are you saying
that you're correlating those
eighty two those two scenarios
that you just mentioned for
example yeah so so the number
of wells that washed up on
shore we can gas or with some
analogies to difference studies
have been done on other species
that are out between less
than one percent and about
twenty percent of whatever
killed make it to shore and
so -- you can take the numbers
doesn't counted and multiply
it by about twenty to get that
and that's what's so that's
another way to get out of the
number will serving collection
strikes any that is close to
the numbers that we found in
our fault so -- so then the
model is first represent the
actual number of whales why so
many fans so fin whales have
a much larger population and
there are also distribute a
little bit for the offshore
so that may be except for in
southern California with a
lot of traffic so so those two
factors are really within the
northeast you mentioned speed
restrictions as well as traffic
routes -- is this with in state
waters -- that at these are
these informal rules talked
with people go little deeper to
that yeah so on the east coast
there's a mix of things there's
-- where they call seasonal
management areas where there
are speeds instituted in the
time of year when the whales
are most likely to be present
-- and those are usually
established where there are
known to be high abundances of
the whales who's overseen the
rules so that no -- puts those
rules in place and the Coast
Guard forces -- -- no -- are
you has a role in enforcement
-- and then as far as routing
of ships generally if we can
know where the whales tend to
agree and that's consistent
year to year that's -- of big
copy on -- then we can guide
ship traffic around that and
that can be within state waters
so that official ship lanes
for example here off of San
Francisco go out just about
to -- the shelf break which is
about thirty miles off shore so
we're looking at some of that
and bring it in state waters
and some federal close today
and you believe you said you
believe that that has had a
positive impact is far sure
wells being -- killed in
just is it in a bottle Takasu
walking through that yet note
that there has been a lot of
research done on the right
whales and these guys because
they are so endangered and
so the research has shown
that since those rules were
instituted there's been
decreases of -- up to eighty
percent in terms of the ship
strikes so it's a major factor
-- there's a big difference
in terms of the quality the
whales there because right
whales are so coastal and
they're so well known as a lot
fewer of them so it becomes
more challenging here on the
west coast I think but none
the less so seven other thing
too it's important to note is
that no has been working on
this issue particularly within
the shipping lanes here off
of the because the bay area
and the Santa Barbara channel
and they do have voluntary
speed limit -- and there has
been some corporation by the
shipping industry but it's
moderate compared to the
corporation seen on the east
coast where those regulations
are required in the are there
any consequences any fines in
place -- and he's coast on the
east coast yes yes there are
fines for shipping companies
that do not comply with those
people this is going to add
that in Alaska other similar
results -- and in Alaska
the deal specifically with
humpbacks which are more common
out with us so it's with the
final ask is consistent with
what he said about this because
you mentioned -- disaster
service workers in being able
that I get that implemented
for those who are out -- -- in
the intake on the detailing the
teams anything else that you
think we should know prior to
concluding this panel that the
all the all of the official --
responders or actually -- put
into certain levels depending
on their experience ability
and and so on and the --
functional responded for level
two three and four of us got
to level three -- Brian backer
flow three available for and
so we are all recognized and
we are on the national permit
one eighty seven eighty six
as recognized isn't paying
works and so we have a way
of training evaluating and
advancing a proper disobeying
orders respond this is there
anything else you think you
may need obviously resources
what we heard you say is -- --
the way it was in the on the
misspell it not listing knows
who are at a -- a dissenting
the whales would be to be a
clean up correct the other
piece that we heard is -- the
the disaster service worker a
decoration anything else before
we conclude that you think we
need to be able to know of the
last two years there's been of
emergency funds of parks on the
hundred thousand dollars yeah
which has greatly -- helped
our situation hasn't solved it
but it did provide the ability
to -- pay for one third of
the cost of a proper response
vote for five of the stranding
network participants and so now
we have some standardization
in the state so that Scott can
go down to Long Beach and have
the exact same vote that he
uses up in moss landing and and
then affected disenchantment
sort coming coming up with some
standardization and if we can
get that as a minimum -- we
can continue -- advancing what
we're doing thank you semester
Jim thank you so much
your timer the grateful
thank you for a job today
we're not gonna be moving on
-- with our hearing to our
second last panel this one is
-- really going deeper on the
issues in actions that have
been made across the state
to reduce risks of well table
made from fishing activities
we have several individuals
whose get we're going to be
coming up and I talked with
us today we're going to be
bringing up Kelly say see who's
the administrator California
scrap fishing gear working
group if you could please come
forward wagered Santora whose
associate associate researcher
from university California
Santa Cruz go banana slugs
sake master -- program manager
marine region of the coffin
apartment fish and wildlife we
have our doctor Chester who is
the capital program director
for ocean as well de clock
commercial fishermen from the
database and we're grateful
that Kelly is here she's going
to provide an overview of the
working group its charge what
it's been doing in talking
about its progress as well
and some of the highlights
from eighteen nineteen Kelly
we're gonna kick us off it's
always good to see you welcome
back you have five minutes
-- much thank you very much --
my name is Kelly sees and I am
the principal and co founder
of strategic or consulting
and have the pleasure of
serving as an administrator of
the California dungeons crab
fishing you're working group
which I will refer to as the
working group throughout I
just want to acknowledge has
been some really wonderful
comments already made about
the working group's effort so I
will try to not duplicate what
has been said but hopefully
further enhance I'm so we
certainly want to thank the
drink twenty for having here
today thank you so much on
behalf of the working group
so in September twenty fifteen
since been shared that the
department of fish and wildlife
in partnership with names and
-- PC a convene -- a working
group to identify and be
responsive to this elevated
risk at elevated levels of
-- intake of at risk and
entanglements into just cried
fishing here and I won't go
into the composition of the
working group has been talked
about a lot but I think that
in addition to this diverse
group of stakeholders to come
together it's also important
to acknowledge that they're
surrounded by scientists
and such as doctor your ten
Torah legislative can I stop
consultants such as Tom west
low -- and others in the room
including Peter full cans who
act as advisers to the working
group to help supplement
their efforts the group is
committed as we've talked
about to identifying solutions
that support thriving we'll
populations and other marine
life along the west coast
in a thriving unprofitable
dungeons crab fishery and has
identified a number priority
areas to center their efforts
including improving available
data gathering and reporting
exploring gear modifications
and other technological
innovations and also our region
communications to the industry
and others as has also been
discussed -- in may twenty
seventeen there group started
to develop and produce a
process to identify and assess
elevated levels of entanglement
risk to determine the need for
management options to reduce
risk of entanglements and that
is that risk insights and risk
assessment and mitigate and
program the ramp and we have
doctors in as interim Mister
master who be speaking more
about the details of the ramps
I won't go into for a lot
of that but there are these
conditions are factors that
the working group focuses on
such as borage distribution
oceanographic conditions --
distribution in concentration
of whales and things like
season delays to understand
how that informs the relative
level of risk of foreign ting
commence the lessons learned
-- or maybe I'll to say first
that for the working group
to be effective it requires
consistent reliable and
standardized informations
we've been talking a lot
about the data that needs to
be available to help inform
on the ramp in this effort
the working group supports
and is involved in a number
of collaborative research
projects to help inform the
ramp including aerial surveys
solo longer pilot testing gear
modifications and innovations
and developing bass fishing
practices and Jeff Chester
and Dick Aug who are working
group participants here on
the panel I will be sharing
updates and their perspectives
on these projects in just a
moment this is learned from
the twenty seventeen eighteen
eighteen ramp pilot were at
fault evaluated by the working
group and the twenty eighteen
nineteen ramp reflects those
updates -- and the working
group welcomes feedback on the
ramp including how to better
assess risk considerations for
possible management measures
and suggestions related to new
technologies and information
learned by of your during
the twenty eighteen nineteen
ramp will be shared with
this committee in addition
to the department names OPC
the fish and game commission
into the California dungeons
crap task force as that's
available to just very briefly
on the working group is deeply
appreciative of the legislature
for allocating seven and a half
million dollars at the general
fund to the OPC to address
the issue of will internal
in tangle men and Jeff we
sharing a few highlights on the
working group's twenty eighteen
nineteen recommendations
which included unanimous or
unanimous request for the OPC
to allocate general finds --
funding for the ramp operations
-- we've heard that one of
those projects has been awarded
which is wonderful and thank
you and that in that memo that
includes those recommendations
was submitted to the joint
committee on fisheries and
aquaculture in October are
the working group would like
to think senator McGuire
free support in developing
Senate bill thirteen oh nine
which included a number of
recommendations made by the
working group -- in the during
the twenty seventeen eighteen
season and one that the --
maybe important to highlight
as was just mentioned recently
one is requiring standardized
cure marking to be implemented
by January first twenty twenty
which the department will work
with other fisheries are is the
intention to help address the
significant number of unknown
cure types of this conversation
around here markings and
then also as was discussed
permitting the director of
fish and wildlife the internet
thirty as of January first
twenty nineteen to respond in
consultation with the working
group to circumstances at
elevated entanglement rescue
into teeny to work together
with the working group the
department in partnership
I'm in others to adopt the
criterion protocol to evaluate
and response to potential
entanglement risk moving
forward to the working group
I continues to be committed
to the work -- improper story
I'm just gonna say one other
thing qualities on the working
group would like to also
acknowledge the proactive steps
that the department is taking
on including implementing
commonsense year surface gear
regulations in title fourteen
for the twenty eighteen
nineteen season which again was
mentioned -- and and beyond the
twenty eighteen nineteen season
to reduce potential integument
hazards and the working group
values to direct communication
and coordination cooperation
with the department of in
developing these regulations
and future regulations thank
you are we continue on behalf
of the working group continues
to be committed to work in
partnership with you all and
and respected federal and
state agencies and also with
the Oregon and Washington
working group's which our
counterparts in other states
that are working on this issue
as well ample pots there thank
you very much thank you so
much for all your of working
please give our sincere thanks
to the group as well please
all the ship all right we're
not gonna be turned over to Mr
San tore a mistress and tore
a -- we are so grateful that
you were here today the --
doctors in Torrance associate
researcher for the user in
receipt California -- he's
gonna be providing really that
ecosystem perspective on --
Ocean Klein made creel all the
forge fish issues -- as well
as potential risks for and --
entanglement in -- doctor I
mean idea also look at warm
water conditions in why that
is being so troublesome out
over the last three years as
well I'm sure you can include
that in the presentation but
if you work you can just add
that to the presentation of
five minutes Sir it's good to
see you thank you so much for
being here thank you chair for
inviting me to speak to the
all right
Hey that's exactly
of their ego alright
okay -- my name is Jared sense
or a hat and I'm a social
researcher the university of
California Santa Cruz and I
study ecosystem dynamics --
Friday different ecosystems
and when the I'd like to make
clear today is that we we need
to make a clear distinction
between indicators like
demo gas and or see service
temperature those indicators
are symptoms of an on health
and environment but it's key
to understanding all this is
to examine the processing is on
there underlying these events
and so that's where I've been
focusing on the last few years
-- I think it's important to
just read live some of this
history because it might --
we might be going through it
again sometime in the future
-- but I was brought on to the
the working group as scientific
adviser in two thousand and
seventeen which I spend so you
know a good good man of the
year developing a synthesis
-- that on this two thousand
fifteen sixteen entitlement
issue and it's a hypothesis
as want to be clear about that
and one thing I haven't heard
today is that one thing that's
key to this is that there's
been a long term increase and
well one of the populations
are recovering combined wells
are recall -- the second
component of the hypothesis
is about the large marine heat
wave that we experience also
known as the blog what that did
was intro habitat compression
warm water encroaches upon our
coast and there was still good
up Welling in twenty fifteen
twenty sixteen it was just
very minimal compared to the
past we had good up well and
was very very restricted along
the coast on that for system
he heatwave -- correlated
with the of the prevalence
of persistence of tomorrow
okay acid that we know about
and it also resulted in the
confines of creel populations
and -- there was basically no
food in town for the wells it
gives me great pleasure when I
hear about directors everyone
produce my Ste the said the
system down to a few soundbites
that means I've got my message
across the group populations
tanks and the only food that
was available was a near shore
anchovy concentration and
this is from the perspective
of a humpback whale they will
switch over to beating on for
traditional move ensure where
there's food available to
them arms that pre switching
is a key aspect of their
behavior and their behavior is
fundamentally different when
they're feeding on Carrillo
versus the feeding on fish
the more acrobatic and more --
like Peter showed in his -- is
some of this video there with
the Wells twist around a bit
more than a bit more active
when they're feeding on fish
versus creel they can just go
down deep and then swim through
across -- but this the third
component is that this ample
fight co occurrence as we heard
earlier all the gear that one
out due to the fishing delay
that one out late twenty April
twenty sixteen result in a lot
of entanglements but one thing
I want to make clear is that
there was just money there is
nearly as many entanglements
in twenty fifteen the pres
the previous season as it was
during the the the the other
we had a fishing delay and that
was because of this habitat
compression that happened to
the blog so the end result
which is consecutive years of
high tide spacetime overlap
forging wells and fishing
our this is a time line that
I put together that kinda
illustrates this ecosystem
perspective as we move from two
thirteen was which was a record
phenomenal cold upwelling
year creel populations were
plentiful there all the hot
spots that were available to
wells were were available and
then in late twenty fourteen
the blob starts to can starts
to develop three that we
had an el Nino that combined
with the blob that impacted
the the whole -- appalling
ecosystem of California but
shortly after that after
twenty sixteen delay what part
of the reason why you see a
decline in the entanglements
that we return to normal cool
up Welling conditions in the
creel population started to
come back principle pray for
the wells of this kind of
just walk through some of the
the key elements of the price
which behavior in some of the
the for jobs and conditions
this synthesis that I that
I worked up and I presented
the working group -- enabled
us to come up with the risk
assessment mitigation program
in terms of these different
season seasonal assessments
preseason the mid season in
the late season Kelly had
mentioned sake will expand on
one of the key aspects of this
is this first points a basin
scale -- some potion climate
and regional condition drives
winter and spring time up well
and we have a lot we are rich
one time series in California
thirty over thirty year time
series that I've I've played on
heavily to produce the senses
we know exactly what's going
to happen in in spring if we
look at the winter time there's
a connection there we can make
predictions going forward --
so these preseason mid season
late season components for the
different aspects of the ocean
forage community is something
that we've been we've developed
and inserted into the ramp
currently it's unfunded the
working on on funding not going
forward -- I just wanna give
a few of perspectives these
are my perspectives not the
working group's perspectives
in can I I want to commend what
I've heard in this room about
the at the state of California
I think we should be proud
that we're leading this charge
against the way on trying
one issue and and funding
this working incredible --
collection of people and this
is a west coast problem it's
not strictly California it's
occurring all over the coast in
Oregon Washington we're getting
males earned ten with gear
from organ washing that are
showing up in California I've
switch gears I'm thinking about
this as a coast Y.
problem terms of Krillin
for education oceanographic
dynamics that's my first point
-- future entitlement groups
that are being developed either
in other states they should
look at this working group
and -- big fish commend this
working group and use it as a
basis for developing other risk
assessment programs bringing an
ecosystem science helps defuse
roadblocks among stakeholders
that sets three sets everything
gives everything a nice common
ground I want to personally say
that I feel that the scientific
community fails to get this
message out to the stakeholders
our collection of science as
we knew we saw the blob we knew
that we start to see all the
normal stuff happened we knew
that compared to previous years
another el Nino's we knew that
porridge and krill was going
to tank but we can get that
message out the only came down
to when I met with fishermen
this because this issue I
realize how serious it was
to communicate science so --
so that third point about the
science and Fisher engagement
is absolutely critical for
minimizing Valentine women's
in the future -- I personally
change by chase problems that
I want to get involved in or I
choose not to get in problems
but the methylation ships that
I built with this working group
has -- been incredible and
though the fishermen are key
observers for whaling forage
and then under surveyed winter
season we know very little
about what's going on during
the winter when they are out
there fishing so I just want
to commend the fishermen on
this group and the time and
energy than the communications
I thought about what to the one
good one last thing I'd like
to share is a little bit about
reach I've been developing
-- this is a up so this it
expands and demonstrates how
this is not just a California
problem but this is a west
coast regional problem and this
is a summary of the ocean and
forage factors in geographic
space so we can be digested and
examined by the public and they
can see the various -- factors
in questions that we track
for ocean foraging conditions
and really just highlights
that on very unprecedented --
ecosystem stress test that we
went through in twenty fifteen
and twenty sixteen we can see
these events coming now since
we've developed the processes
underlying them and perhaps
we might be able to model them
in the future but you know we
need more resources to develop
those syntheses and we need
to know that the wells in the
crawl the fortress they don't
respect the boundaries of the
of the state of California
they move throughout this
entire California current
large marine ecosystem so
just wanted to give it up
that this with this will put
about reach that we recently
really nice job thank you very
much -- a grateful for your
perspective eight you said that
that others have been doing
the NSL but you were able to
bring that all down the and
educate out so just once a
thank you so much for all your
work looking for work with
you here as we move forward
we're not gonna be bringing for
talking master from the barn a
program manager -- California
proposition wildlife he's
gonna be focusing on the ramp
process and what the future
holds -- in really what tools
we could use better predict
the risk of entanglement in
what actually should be taking
it easy Sir your five minutes
I thank you good afternoon
thanks for inviting me and
thanks for all the panels that
have helped us explain what
we think is our path to the
success and I also I can we
really want to take advantage
of the questions I heard
already today from both occur
-- senator stone in center
McGuire which is where do we
go from here you've heard quite
a bit about the ramp content
in terms of membership in the
basic tools -- but how's it
actually going to work and what
do we still need to understand
so the fundamentals are as
we need gear that's doesn't
catch whales that that's a
goal we don't have that the
other of course in till that
happens or if it happens the
others avoiding co occurrence
or extreme co currents of gear
and Wales the good news on the
gear front we have a lot of
very smart fishermen scientists
engineers and biologists
working on trying to figure out
here that won't catch while --
we're not there yet nobody's
figure that out -- but I will
say about the gear solution --
it's easy to technically come
up with a solution it's a whole
nother thing to come up with a
solution that what I say fishes
eighty it's economically viable
for the fisherman to use and
doesn't create other unintended
consequences so -- it's it's a
lot harder than it sounds the
other is a co current you heard
quite a bit about predicting
whale behavior but there's
other half of this that is
equally as complex and hard
to get out its understanding
fishermen their complex group
we have very many and many
different business models
and approaches to risk and
fishing practices so for us to
really get this car currents
we have to spend more time
understanding our fishermen
how they make decisions about
how much gear they face how
long the fishing where the fish
and the things that influence
at price abundance là mÙt
cast said it sounds obvious
but one thing I've learned
working with a fisherman it's
not obvious cam so we're gonna
spend a need to spend more time
really understanding that and
that's critical not only for
predicting that undesirable
coal currency but if we are
seeing in project in a co
occurrence what are we actually
going to do to reduce that
risk ultimately -- can I tell
Fishman will just move your
gear can actually do that how
much time does it take to move
back here does it is influenced
by the size of their operation
the size their permit a do
they have to move five hundred
potter wonder pot does that
change from beginning the
season to the end of the scene
so it's a complex dynamic that
were only just now starting to
work on but we will be working
on a quite a bit getting inside
their heads and figure out a
way to really better project
how they will react both in
time and space when we have
a project in the current goal
currents because if you for
this ramp to work core the
ramp is to assess and predict
a KO currents and then make
recommendations to the director
to avoid tobacco currents and
therefore eliminate or reduce
the risk of well tangle but we
have to know how the fishermen
are going to react the wells
are gonna do their things
because last time I talked
to him they did not listen to
me at all -- I'm not sure the
fishermen well but worth that's
the part we have the best hope
for -- so to the ramp operation
as you heard we piloted this
is our second pilot year were
work in a voluntary basis
trying to work the bugs out
of the system identify the
weaknesses as I just mentioned
fishermen behaviors and one of
the weaknesses we identified
were working on -- the other of
course you heard your marking
-- we'll most of the tangle
men's that are confirmed an
identifiable to the fishery
are to Dungeness crab and
that's because they're they're
the most predominant in terms
of gear but they're also the
one that's mark -- duty --
center Maguire's wisdom he
introduced legislation we will
be requiring all fixed gear to
have some unique identifying
markings so that when we do
get entanglement we are able
to trace at least to the
fishery and so when our source
solution addresses the actual
problem and not just a symptom
that's going to be critical
-- the other thing we're gonna
be looking at is improving
that turn around time on our
information so -- the agencies
monitor information that's
coming in we're developing
more -- data streams including
fishermen we started and tested
last year -- text groups I'm
not a really technical savvy
person I'm learning a lot from
the fishermen where we farm
groups and they Texas live
information of what they're
seeing on the water where
they're seeing it behavior the
whales how much gear on the
way in on the train here this
morning I got tax from fish
missing his not much gear here
that's kind of strange where
they're pretty go so that it
turns out to be very valuable
last year we had a report of an
enormous number of well citing
tough Monterey right before the
season right around that you
back two minutes that caused
us great concern we checked
with the fishermen through this
tax single will were not seen
the whales so that causes to
investigate further than the
were in close to shore the
whales were way off shore no
Kirk CO a current and we were
relieved so that's the kind
of dynamics this group's gonna
have to work with and then you
know Hey we don't have to but
at some point where we realize
we have an an act unacceptable
event that's about to occur
we have to have a mechanism to
both communicate to the fleet
a you need to do this in this
amount of time and then have
some way to make sure they can
actually accomplish that or
provide assistance for them to
be able to do that so those are
kind of the things were working
on going forward is actually
to be able to implement and
see results through the system
and I'll available for any
questions you might have
very grateful for all your
work in the even at this many
years in we so appreciate so
keep thank you very much for
being here today it's always
good to see will be asking
questions here just a bit
we're grateful to Dr Jeff
masters here he's the captain
program director for Oceania
he's gonna be addressing his
experience with the working
group process including some
options in regards to future
work and potential studies
as well Jeff's could you see
Sir for Georgia five minutes
a very much Chen McGuire --
vice chair stone it's really
an honor to be here thank you
for the invitation with them
by the way a at fish team tap
I had to I got my crap socks
on to all right Hey we got
your own their doubts -- so
I'm I'm gonna talk today on
behalf of -- Oceania as well
as -- my my -- colleague --
Andre trees worth justice is
also on the working group --
representing the organization
-- I want to start by saying
that whales and the marine by
our environment are important
of the people of California and
one of the things that makes me
so excited to be on the working
group is that we have a shared
vision of both thriving marine
life and thriving fisheries I
love the crab and want to see
that just just as much as I
want to see you healthy Wales
so I think that we're not
none of us want to see these
animals entangled in our waters
and similar the value the
Pacific leatherback sea turtle
California state marine reptile
is critically endangered and
in the Klein and also risk
of entanglement so today
I'm gonna be discussing some
highlights from the working
group's recent twenty eighteen
nineteen recommendations and
also provide a brief overview
of some gear innovation testing
-- the result involving rope
was fishing gear that the I've
been involved with -- first
on behalf of the conservation
community we're very grateful
to the legislature for passing
SB thirteen oh nine which led
by center McGuire providing
the department with authority
and direction to implement
this rant program we've been
talking about as well as for
that a seven point five million
in in general funds to assist
the OPC in finding solutions
we really commend the the crab
fleet for really stepping up
and recognizing this issue
-- right from the get go also
the Dungeness crab task force
in the department and the the
members that have dedicated
their time in the working
group towards really solving
a very difficult problem
and and building trust and
partnership together including
-- want to mention some of
the new regulations on surface
gear that the department just
implemented as well as the
commitment that was announced
today by the apart department
-- the working group has
really made some strides in
understanding this we have
spent hours going through
the data on this in trying
to understand the science
that the doctors and torrent
others have brought to us and
we really want to ensure that
all the separate results in
an effective program so the
last three years of of our
deliberations is really --
developed what we consider to
be a very solid framework to
begin addressing this problem
and so I wanted to highlight
-- three -- three three kind of
areas so what we on the on the
crowd on the on the solutions
-- piece -- we've developed a
whole new number of of areas
that have have really been
-- critical towards -- moving
forward with this and I'm gonna
jump actually to the next --
slide here one of the first
key questions we have to ask
getting to solve these issue of
of co occurrence of the year is
where the whales in the turtles
and the gear actually at and so
this is an example -- picture
of a of a -- aerial survey
results that shows -- what's
on he was actually just talking
about where you could see the
whales in relation to wear the
gear is and evaluate whether
there is co occurrence or not
and where it might be -- the
working group is recommended
expanding these aerial and
vessel surveys conducting more
the forge analysis -- it's
connecting tagging studies of
the whales using well watching
data developing predictive
models partnering with the U.
S. Coast Guard and then also
expanding the -- the use of
these solar data loggers and
and really the many of these
have yet to be funded and the
working group has requested the
OPC fund this work one being --
the solar data loggers -- that
has been done these basically
track fishing vessel locations
-- to identify where traps
are being set while protecting
protecting the confidential
proprietary individual in the
beginning information -- so
this was recently -- expanded
based on a recommendation
and the OPC recently did fund
this work and we -- -- as a
conservation communities do
this is a step on the right
direction I would encourage
the state to move toward a
goal of a hundred percent --
data logger coverage across
all its fix your fisheries
this is something that is
going to have an about major
pay offs in understanding
the fishing dynamics -- and
also understanding how to
better enforce and fine tune
regulations as well as with
the effects of any regulations
we might put in might be --
regarding -- the next kind
of piece of this and the gear
innovations front the working
group represent recommended the
open ocean protection council
work with the Pacific states
marine fisheries commission
to develop a cure innovations
review -- and evaluation
process while supporting it
of Asian projects that might
be ready to go this season of
so I'm in a skip to the next
slide here -- today of the talk
about a type of your innovation
known as roll bliss -- fishing
gear so right now one thing
that we do know is one sure
way to lower risk is to reduce
the number of vertical lines
in the water this either means
closing specific areas during
periods of high risk for using
technologies -- that actually
might allow continued fishing
without the vertical lines and
this we believe is the promise
of reckless here we're not
asking you today to require
real click here at this time
as an alternative but would
really like your support in
further testing to see if we
can turn this into a viable
solution in the future -- so
this technology has been used
for decades in the scientific
and defence sectors -- they've
been proven to reliably locate
retrieving communicate with
underwater equipment using
acoustic release devices and
modems and while applying these
mature technologies to fishing
year -- will require more are
in the efforts we must remember
we can go from the model T.
to the test le overnight
California is famous for its
innovation just look at Silicon
Valley and the legislature
can really play a key role
in supporting the innovation
process and developing this
type in New new technology
-- so we've done some --
next slide please we've we've
actually already conducted some
proof of concept tests -- with
three California Dungeness crab
fishermen -- summer here are in
the room including a deck here
on the panel I am take valuable
information on how to modify
these existing systems to work
better on private schools -- we
also can be in a meeting with
the marine mammal commission to
talk about further testing --
plans for this upcoming fishing
season and multiple fisherman
now have expressed interest
in participating in a full
operational pilot test program
over an extended period to work
toward making this robust year
more of a fully operational
-- option and address many of
the challenges identified thus
far such is fully developing
a shipboard operations making
the systems more affordable
on a larger scale addressing
concerns over Ocean noise and
enabling enforcement of trap
fisheries that don't have a
service but we give that to
me right -- I presented a some
of this work -- recently at
the rogue was kind I'm in new
Bedford Massachusetts attended
by over a hundred fifty --
fishermen scientists and
government agencies and this
effort is gaining momentum so
-- the environmental community
gear manufactures and fishermen
are are seeking financial
support and next slide please
-- to to to to to to try to
pursue testing this current
season this is a photo of some
of the testing -- that that
was on you can see the the
movie being that there after
a successful release -- next
slide please -- this is -- in
the words of a caller dialing
one of the fishermen -- feel
who has great potential for
being beneficial used to the
for the fishery and trap issues
around the world including
mitigation well integument
and more thorough technology
-- testing the technology
for should be the next step
next line so in terms of what
we're trying to do basically
seek funding to actually get
this -- gear on the water this
coming season -- and also --
we were hoping that the --
ocean protection council we
can work with the department
to develop a longer term a
robust testing a comprehensive
program for the future of go
ahead next line -- and so what
the other last recommendation
wanted to highlight from the
working group is that the ramp
currently -- only addresses
the Dungeness crab fishery
and is really primarily focus
on humpback whales and so one
of the recommendations is to
really expand the scope of this
discussion all the commercial
and recreational fix your
fisheries that use vertical
lines this will require action
by the fish and game commission
that apartment the legislature
and California's work in
the federal Pacific fishery
management council and this
discussion also needs to move
beyond just humpback whales
the working group is record
recommended moving out to blue
whales -- and there and and
and and the other species that
are subject to entanglements
so in summary we're really
encouraged by the progress that
has been made just next slide
-- deserves a picture doing
some of the testing -- we were
a part of this is really been
an exciting for -- thing for me
personally and professionally
I really -- -- built some great
relationships with some of the
people on this committee --
and -- and I think that if we
can -- didn't didn't have a
science driven framework for a
solution and and make further
investments in the day a
collection development of these
new technologies and expansion
of the ramp framework to all
the fisheries I think we are
are on the verge of having a a
solution and it's great to go
first as a state it's it makes
me proud to live here thank
you so much Jeff thank you so
much and have some questions
on that -- and some of the --
cordless aye traps as well so
happening coming up in just
a bit and it is our pleasure
to be able entities Mister
Augie's commercial fishermen
religion here in California
he's in cover the fisherman's
perspective -- a and I gotta
say the fleet came to us in two
thousand fifteen proactively
to be to say we have to be
a change the dynamic on the
ocean as one take a moment say
thank you to the fleet -- very
few industries that would say
come regulate is I a and do
it quickly and I just want to
say on behalf of the committee
thank you miss rob -- for
bring that forward along with
that the rest of the fleet
you're gonna be a focusing on
education outrage the fleet --
as well as -- all the different
meetings have been happening
to gear modifications even
advancing the floor is yours
yet by Sir okay -- my name is
Dick log in -- I'm a commercial
fisherman from the day today
I have the fishing vessel
carrying gene and I like to
take a couple seconds in --
new tell you that I've been on
the working group now for the
last couple of years and --
you feel very very lucky to be
able to participate with them
and work from that point one of
the things that comes to mind
initially is one of the things
that the -- the working group
put together was but a best
practices guide that was --
distributed through the fleet
and help to -- take a look at
line school -- excessive line
service secure and -- kind
of recommended what we felt
was of an appropriate way to
fish -- it it it decrease the
amount of excess line it was
on service and and of hopefully
-- decrease the amount of
opportunity for entanglement
with with the -- whales the the
end product -- I I I feel was
that that made the fisherman
it helped the fishermen be
more wear and the help is
fish responsibly and I feel
like that's a very strong and
definite direction that we
need to continue -- allows been
said about the solar loggers
I'm just trying to -- -- --
-- summarize this is much as
quickly as possible the soul
soul loggers we I've had as a
little girl my vessel for the
last two years it's -- it's
a great product -- it doesn't
require any -- wiring and
some simple it works of a cell
signal as we enter into the
service area where can transmit
it immediately transmits the
location and the information
vessel as as -- -- eight
tracks the vessel and then
transmitted information I feel
like it's a of a very viable
of -- solution for indicating
three dynamics and of location
and effort shift in all the
things that are important to
of the ramp program and -- the
other things that we're testing
or are like a weak link type
devices which are -- of one of
our are working group members
actually is working with the
view degradable line -- the
idea behind this would be to
have the plot fall off of the
wheel if possible if it does
get entangled and therefore
you know if the line is degree
double and it's on the --
animal for a period of time you
can break fall away and take
the stress of the the creature
and allow the this entanglement
group to potentially come up in
disentangle the animal easier
without the stress of the --
part on the bottom there we've
also -- been given some of the
sleeve devices from back east
-- day or another weak link
device and of the best thing
about that would be is that I
didn't have to splice the line
all the time and put put these
notes in here reached here if
I can avoid that I'd love to
be able to do that but at the
the sleep devices similar to
that -- okay describe is like a
Chinese finger deal the little
puzzle you put your fingers in
there you can't fully figures
out well that that slides over
the into the ropes we read that
into the world and windows is
an excessive amount of stress
put on that that -- that wrote
the rope will break and I've
tried it the house I've worked
with my trucks and pulled on
and it does break in and and
it and it holds very very well
the idea behind this would be
to keep it up in the upper ten
fathoms of of rope and then
you know that's apparently
or that's where we feel them
the most in in that way that
will is entangled the most is
on the upper end of the crab
here so if in fact we were
able to utilize a breakaway
of some type at the at the it
would it would it would help
-- keep damage or people keep
the animal from being injured
as much -- about two minutes to
open I'm sorry it too many all
okay -- I have a as a as Jeff
is as we mentioned -- you know
I've worked with the public
Louise -- there's a awful lot
to be they need they need to
work a lot on that it's it's
it's not real practical -- for
the fishery at this point I
believe that it it maybe later
on -- I'm more than willing
to try to work with it but --
at this point it's just not
something that we can utilize
efficiently in the in the
fishery -- we've also done care
testing with a GPS grease which
-- would be something that --
eight eight eight indicates
when we lost year or cure gets
out of line and we'd be able to
for find it on a chart plotters
that as another technology
that's coming around -- it also
would allow us to follow the
wheel efficiently if infected
to get tangled and rather
than having to keep it inside
include followed on a chart
and be able to see it from you
know utilizing GPS accordance
is -- the main thing I'd like
to be able to emphasize is
the effort that the fishermen
have made to recover lost here
and not to of the move the
vertical lines from the water
of with the support from center
McGuire -- we I I'm I'm sure
this is going to improve and
did these efforts of a crackpot
recovery had it up in if the
if they have been around for
quite awhile we've we've gone
up we've gone out of her way
to make sure that we bring is
gearing so -- want one thing
I just would like to leave you
with is that you know -- you've
got some really innovative
minds out here the fishermen
are incredibly intelligent
and and I mean I I I highly
respect their their efforts
and energy to try to mitigate
these issues so please reach
out to us and and and thank you
for your support think so much
Mister operate for your here
thank you for all your work
and then also -- tested at the
different pieces of equipment
as well as so important being
able to go out the field next
to see how they work thank you
so much thank you to turn over
the vice chair of any questions
comments or if you come some
of the things that that I'm
hearing in in part of it I do
so my questions before about
the case of a tangle mania
where were fining tangle but
really all goes back to the
science the data collection
and building professors you
really talked about ultimately
we can start to figure this
out in California but if we
don't view it as a west coast
problem then we're not going
to be finding the the real long
term solutions and indicates
you said the we we we can talk
about gear we can talk about
science but proving it on the
ground so that something is
fissionable that solutions
are are realistic and part of
that is the credibility that's
built by the science by the
data collection and having
the ramp and in the end the
coalition's the passports of
really being able to bring
the stakeholders together and
and have this conversation so
I see that we've been making
a lot of progress but I think
we're really also pointing out
where we have some gaps in the
data gaps in funding gaps in in
would be able to bring science
to bear so that we can we can
continue these conversations
but then inevitably expand --
up the coast where we're gonna
need to bring in other states
eventually we will have with
the west coast federal partners
and think are proving to be
fruitful is because federal
partners not so much time will
sort of hopefully sort that out
but it's a big issue and
it's it's amazing to hear
about the strides that
making but it also is a
the the areas where we really
need to be putting more into
think that's why these kids
here is a very helpful and
keeping the committee very well
connected to what's working
and what's not working is
hopefully if one of we can
bring nothing else to bear
but some of the resources of
the the capacity that you're
going to need to be able to
answer this question that some
that were very interested in
like things like GPS the cost
of those are coming down and
putting those of bullies is
something that's that's really
very feasible but yet it's
an additional cost sufficient
itself we're interested in
that and I think we need to
come up with funding mechanisms
to be able to sure that we're
getting the solution out ground
tested and really understand
the feasibility but that's one
thing to that that if you can
track that year you'll be able
to see for the quickly that
it's been a table because it's
moving in a way that it should
be moving and so with that
those kinds of early morning
in a sort of back to the the
questions about how long that
that will had been entangled
in the damage the gets done
over time the sooner we can
identify that a PC gears moving
forward should be moving back
to the front of the building
we go five back close to the
origin and not have to wait
until it so much further down
the coast where to do it has
a dam is that it is so those
are the kinds of things that
we should be paying attention
to but again it's resources and
it's testing things out to to a
point where it becomes workable
side not necessarily for here
but I would be very interested
to know because doctor says
you very interesting you saying
that that the robust years
really putting out to be viable
but from the fishermen stable
interest but not necessarily
officials at this point does
the gaps that that we've
gotta close it may be able
to establish a lot more so
I mean I'm just if you're a
capsule a kind of the kinds of
things that are working with
the technologies that have
been with the intensity of the
interesting the things that
I'd like to say is that you
know we need to be sure that
any of these devices that we're
working on our of one number
number one cost effective
and number two or something
as simple that the fishermen
can put together in utilized
immediately it's it's very
very difficult to begin to we
invent the wheel and have have
let's try to put something
together that just is very
difficult to operate with or
with or equipment we've got is
a way that we do this and it's
very efficient and -- I you
know I want to make sure that
whatever we were doing doesn't
in able impact is financially
that mean significantly you
know we've already gone through
group changing we tried to
of a lemonade floating lines
we tried to go to neutral
wanted sinks keep these lines
tie -- we're doing a lot of
things to try that are simple
not very not very expensive
for the fishermen and that's
extremely important because
we're we're we're basically
struggling now as it is and and
to impact is more financially
that's a that's a tough one
for all for the whole three
okay yeah so copies -- cost
year compatibility with which
you have on the boat versus
what's in the water that's
great yeah that's it okay
died I understand that come
and then the a lot better --
thank you this is always been
very informative and I think
we're really laying out the
past as well as the continuing
challenge that we have in
order to be able to solve this
problem but I do agree starting
to look more west coast
rather than just California
thank you thinks which is
fresher would like to talk
about the events -- could you
see what we saw two thousand
fifteen more frequently
occurring and then I also
want talk about modeling so
we looked at September October
is the peak this year --
in regards to the mall cash
said then we started to see
it simmer down -- here as we
approach the end of the year is
that something that folks saw
what we need to be a to do to
be you have a better prediction
model -- as we move for
I think you're getting very
good advice on the demo casted
from professor Cannella and
-- the one thing I'll say
about this this coming season
is -- the north Pacific is
anomalously warm this this
this one this one and that's
concerning and some have --
suggested that we might see
the return of a small warm
blog this winter many for the
Michael and that that that does
happen we would see persistent
demo castle and reduction of up
Welling reduction of our normal
porridge community that we have
regarding long term outlook
-- it's been hypothesized
that upwelling intensity is
going to increase with global
warming and I think there's
number studies now that have --
demonstrated that in fact that
has happened over the last four
four decades -- but the thing
that I'm most concerned with
-- we can have all the great
up Welling we we can have with
all the changes and wins and
-- atmospheric conditions but
that it can be destabilizing
could remove the typical forage
base of creel in rock fishing
things and moving off shore
and so we can actually be
detrimental to our ecosystem
that we have dependent on and
one of the biggest concerns
that I've tried to highlight
is that with increased --
ocean warming Kering off
shore wonder things that we're
expecting to happen is that
the cold water habitat is
going to be compressed closer
to short as can be we might
have good up willing but only
be a tiny sliver and that's
when we run into problems when
the predators that typically
live out in the open ocean the
large cetaceans and other sea
birds when they can't find food
they're coming on to the shelf
that puts them into direct
interaction with humans papers
so that that that's sort of a
long term perspective that we
think we're gonna see more --
frequent heat waves of rain
heatwaves right and lack of and
reduction of up Welling habitat
one California coast in your
seen this in other areas of
the plan as well yes yeah you
can law you can do a search for
large marine heat waves there's
actually a really nice --
website that makes predictions
it's not a matter of time there
it is there's heat waves right
now all over the earth and
they have a as we've learned
here in California they have
drastic impacts on our social
economic conditions absolutely
-- two thousand fifteen how
would you characterize the
event in a to -- so we're
coming out of that the worst
drought California's had twelve
hundred years how would you
describe the event in two
thousand fifteen unprecedented
we have never seen that before
and here you got to keep
in mind that the long term
record of of observations of
global temperature at that
are a reliable -- coming
from ship based measurements
and stuff like that it's
only about a hundred years
of our a record -- sure we
have other information that
goes back in with high scores
another sentiment coursing
things but in terms of the
the destabilizing affect at
that emergence of the blob
in el Nino in twenty fifteen
twenty sixteen we've never
seen anything like that before
and earlier comment was that
you know California's one
of the highest bio diversity
places and and the state in
the country -- in things that
kept us off very early was
extreme biodiversity positive
anomalies in the open ocean
coming from subtropical as
were cut week we saw the first
tropical is ation of bands that
we that we never see we've had
species we were caught in the
long term troll surveys that
I work with and especially
surveys over thirty years
we've never seen this species
composition before had critters
are coming from the south
and further offshore and the
pirates arms or another another
great example that nots those
of those larger see -- I see
tackle things of the Washington
beach yeah yeah we've never
seen this change I think we
had a squid harvest up in --
crescent city -- which was
just a unbelievable yeah yeah
it was an eco system stress
test driven by climate change
that we've never seen before
and -- I hope we don't see
more frequent events but it's
it's likely that we will it's
not a matter of if it's one
to be able to pull a --
for fisheries because I think
that the peace Lara times in
my issues come down the price
right -- so what is it gonna
take to be able to mass produce
something that is reliable and
how many years out are we sell
two part question number one
how far out are we because at
field testing right obviously
this is more work to be done
is heard from doing any to what
is going to cost to be able to
look at a reliable alternative
to see Dr -- takes at the end
for the question and I've I've
-- I've also been involved
in some of the other -- other
fisheries where you've seen
these kind of new innovations
pop up for example like deep
set do we gear which started
as basically a concept or a
hypothesis that was promising
and involved from proof of
concept tests to expansion
to you know now we're looking
authorization of that as it is
an allowable fishing fisheries
so I would see if a similar
process here I mean we're not
saying that this gear is ready
to use I mean this this is
basically adopting an existing
technology that that's out
there -- so what we've done is
we we put the we put the gear
in the water one day right
just once -- the next step we
would see would be to basically
expand that so you give you
know five or six fishermen you
know a set of these of these
movies and basically train them
and how to use that we would
we would expect that they would
be fairly compensated for all
of their time and involved
in the testing and basically
see if they can integrate and
make the changes on their boat
to make it work right if it
doesn't fish I thought you
said -- there's no point in
even talking about cost and
all the other -- issues there
so I think the the what I I
could see in terms of a a time
line -- you know -- the the
more kind of scaled up pilot
-- study to actually see can
you get this year fish then
what you see what you have is
the basic you know that the
scaling up of technology you
know that the first you know
DVD player with cost about ten
thousand dollars right when it
first came out you go buy one
for less than fifty Bucks today
so that it really it depends on
the of the time the amount that
that the -- they can work with
the fishermen -- to figure out
changes to the system to use
you know less expensive tech
technologies but ultimately --
we would hope that that -- if
that really does prove to be a
solution that there would be --
some partnership some subsidy
types of efforts because it is
in everyone's best interest to
actually -- see this if it's
a solution so it's got promise
out there if it works this
could be the holy grail silver
bullet we're not saying it is
yet we're not convinced yet
but what we've seen so far is
it's got potential and and we
like to try to take the next
step no thank you so yeah I
would just like that because
it there's along with that --
the member the fifth the flea
has two problems Wales and demo
Cassie and one of things were
really interested is learning
to see if we can adapt and
make this fleet nimble enough
to fish around both of those
problems north I see a future
along with gear innovation
where the fisherman's able
to know exactly we have them
on the data monitoring needed
to know where to more gas it
is a problem where the whales
are and they are able to fish
around those problems as an
alternative or a second way
to deal with it because it's
not just one problem may name
a bill solve the whales but
if they can't sell the crowd
there also in trouble so
there's a synergy here that
that we're looking at is nimble
this technology monitoring
predictive tools to kind of
make this a very -- adaptive
fleet going in the future
don't think things myself is
about sharing meals for say
thank you to our entire panel
very very grateful for all the
work with the group is well in
very valuable lessons learned
here today thank you so much
there isn't Chen we really
appreciate you hanging with
us -- al afternoon in again
thank you so much the query
him for all of their work we're
now gonna be moving on to our
last panel this is gonna be
litigation update on all issues
related to well tank commencing
fishing gear we're gonna invite
Christian Monsell to be a to
come for for the cheesy Ocean
program litigation director
also known as the senior
attorney -- for the center for
biological diversity for also
can invite no up and I back
up the ticket director for
the Pacific coast federation
of fishermen's association
I'm here's how it's going to
work -- Kristen is going to
be presenting her perspective
now is going to be presenting
his perspective -- each will
have five minutes and we're
grateful to both you for being
here today then obviously we'll
open it up for questions from
the committee as well after
both a Christian NO a finish up
we're gonna open up for public
comment -- a we do invite you
to stick around for oysters
and crab right after this but
without that further do the
turn of the Christian you have
the floor you five minutes
in our it's causing him to be
governor sizer we can do for
her I can I can do it okay Hey
that it's working the floor
is yours thank you so much
thank you so much time to that
to the chair and members of
the committee and the staff for
organizing this this hearing
and inviting me to to speak and
all the work that you've been
doing to to address this issue
and as you as you know in my
name is Chris my cell and I am
those and legal director at the
center for biological diversity
and will be giving a brief
overview of the the lawsuit
that we we brought -- and
though the law under underlying
that that lawsuit I'm so as
as we all know this is and
why it why we're all here
today California has a whale
entanglement problem we spent
a lot of time already talking
about the numbers so I won't
get into those but as you can
see the number of entanglements
really started to spike or
into the twenty fourteen and
have -- in increased on pretty
pretty astronomically -- since
then you know they have gone
down in twenty seventeen but
are still well well above
the above the average and --
the -- commercial Dungeness
crab fishery in California is
responsible for the most --
number of entanglements when
when the gear type is is now
and -- you know why do we care
about this there's also been
a lot of discussion and with
respect to what happens to
whales when they got entangled
as well as well as the turtles
and as we've heard it causes
an incredible amount injury
is on making kill them because
the years that we have the --
and it can also prevent them
from feeding -- or prevent them
from being able to reproduce in
the future because of the the
straps and the amount of energy
they they expand when they
are entangled -- and it's also
a huge conservation concern
you're talking about humpback
whales blue whales and Pacific
Pacific leatherback sea turtle
all of which are listed as a
threatened or endangered under
the federal Endangered Species
Act and a and several of the
of the populations are are
critically endangered including
both leatherback sea turtles
but then also there's one
population of humpback whales
off California that feeds
exclusively off California
that has just over four hundred
members of the population
laughs so any entanglement of
a member of that population
particularly a female really
kind have population level
impact and may jeopardize the
the very survival of of that
of that population -- and in
addition to being incredibly
painful and and deadly there
-- these entanglements of these
federally protected species are
also unlawful on the Endangered
Species Act is a federal law
that -- sorry about that --
that and seeks to protect that
threaten endangered species and
ecosystems on which they rely
and has been noted has the most
comprehensive legislation for
the protection of endangered
animals ever enacted by any any
nation and the plane intent of
Congress was to reverse I the
trend of species extinction
nope no matter the costs and
one of the most important
ways that the act does that
is through section nine of
the statute which makes it
unlawful for any person to
take an endangered species
or to cause such a take to be
committed -- ghost take and the
person are defined very broadly
under the statute take is
essentially defined as any act
that can harm or wound or caps
or or otherwise just rob --
essential behavioral patterns
like feeding breeding -- and
-- also makes it unlawful to
to kill them and and and under
under the statute it -- you
not just individual people that
are prohibited from causing
take but also -- government
entities Richard of that are
considered a person under
under the statute so if you
had a government entities such
as a state that is permitting
an activity that leads to
entanglements or takes of
whales and sea turtles that is
unlawful and -- that this is
all the basis of a lawsuit that
we filed here in the Northern
District in San Francisco in
October of of twenty seventeen
and we filed it against the
department of fish and wildlife
and we have one claim in the
Los view that the state's
permitted permitting and
management of the commercial
Dungeness crab fishery is
harming killing tangling up
and otherwise causing Tate of
leatherback sea turtles blue
whales and and humpback whales
and that that's a violation of
of the stats you to me okay I'm
almost -- and -- V.
-- we're relief that were
speaking in in the lawsuit
is for the the state to get a
permit from from the federal
government while take is
generally prohibited under the
statute there is an exception
within the statute by which
the federal government can a
permit to take incidental to
an otherwise unlawful activity
provided certain conditions
are met and that there is a
plan to mitigate the impact
of that take on on that the
printer endangered species
and were also seeking a media
many mitigation measures
to significantly reduce the
risk of of entanglement and
fantasize -- immediate here
because there's there's been
a lot of talk about twenty
fifteen and twenty sixteen
and the high number of
entanglements that we saw there
and we are we are very very
concerned about this upcoming
season given not there's lots
of of six signals that we may
see -- another -- another year
of bad entanglements for Wales
and the department absolutely
needs to do everything in its
power to have a plan in place
to to ensure that more whales
and sea turtles Dahle die
these incredibly painful verbal
gaffes and in entanglement in
fishing gear -- any in terms
of the status of the of the
litigation -- were and we're
actively briefing at the --
the merits of the the case
right now time we filed our
opening brief the the end of
October the department just
filed its brief -- along
with PC FFA hood intervened
as defendants in lawsuits --
aye and Wednesday of of last
week -- and we have a brief
DO in a couple weeks and then
-- the state and the CFA will
reply and then we have an oral
argument currently scheduled
for the for the beginning of
affect your eight year the
-- the motions on on summary
judgment and for the court
to determine the liability
this was a thank you so much
Christian noted all trying to
be pushy -- I just wanna make
sure that we give equal time I
mean today so I just I'm very
grateful thank you so much
we're gonna hang with us so
we can ask any questions as
well if you don't mind return
over and no oftentimes with
the music check attracted
specific because federation
official so she should I should
have been of this about seven
minutes and so will I will
double the units back from
a crab feast for nearly that
long Senate we were talking
please note for two hours
so -- no Oppenheim executive
director of the Pacific coast
federation of fishermen's
associations -- I'll pick
up right where miss months a
left off -- as you mentioned
organization is defendant
intervenor in the case on the
side of the department of fish
and wildlife in CVV bottom --
and as month miss once also
mentioned currently we are in
the process of -- of educating
a hearing -- with motions
for summary judgment having
that filed by the center for
biological diversity -- just
a brief update followed by
what I met what I view as a
vision for haves forward both
with respect to litigation
in the working group we've
heard so much about today --
so PC of a file the response
motion which essentially --
supports the department of
fish and wildlife's opposition
on facts and on their motion
for -- their cross motion for
summary judgment -- we are
not taking a position on the
legal jurisdictional side the
section nine take a liability
side per se -- we believe that
department of fish wildlife
is mounting -- a good strong
defense on jurisdictional
and summary judgment process
issues and we would join them
in that defense -- there are
some facts at issue in the
case that will be discussed
at the hearing but what's
not in dispute at all is the
fact that there is a problem
in this fishery there is also
no dispute that the solution
needs to be one that works for
commercial fishermen on the
water I personally believe that
Senate bill thirteen oh nine
thank you for your leadership
Senate required is the path
forward for that -- I believe
that it indeed satisfies the
plea that CVD brings in this
case that we take immediate
and meaningful steps to ensure
that the risk of entanglement
of large marine mammals
industries minimize the ramp in
the working group will do this
with commercial fishermen with
environmental organizations
state and federal agency staff
scientists disentangle next
birds at the table working
together to insure that it's
done equitably expeditiously
fairly and permanently in other
words of a process that will
work I have extreme confidence
in folks like Dick agri heard
from John Miller is also in
the room Jim Anderson also
in the room -- for members
of the working group to both
make sure that what we develop
is going to work on the water
and that their colleagues in
the industry understand that
this is the right path to take
and we will be doing a lot
of work -- organization are
colleagues etcetera to -- to
discuss this issue to make sure
that fishermen understand that
this is not only a progressive
process that will ensure they
are at the table but that it
is a process that will ensure
they will be able to like
director Bonham said fish
crap forever because that's
our ultimate goal and I think
it's the one that shared by
the vast vast majority of
people who are engaged in
this process so -- I'll just
conclude by saying that the
Senate bill thirteen oh nine
framework creating a process
an interim process to bring us
to regulatory implementation
of the ramp is equitable it's
fair the criteria for that
interview process or spelled
out plainly in your bill
senator and greatly appreciate
the fact that those criteria
will make this work at a
workable they will make them
clear transparent they will
protect safety of life at sea
-- the logistical aspects of
the fisheries self and ensure
above all most importantly that
we are able to protect large
remember -- we will get through
this we will weather the storm
and we will come out stronger
for it so thank you thank you
so much Chau very grateful
would like to be turned over
to vice chair to basically
questions or comments please
really it's difficult for
us to comment on on existing
litigation but I think it's the
weather regardless the outcome
of the lawsuit public pressure
and sort of the court of public
opinion is starting to weigh
in more and more significantly
more well it tackles we see
if we do see an uptick it will
take a look I think that's more
pressure on us on everyone in
this room to seek solutions
not in the next three to
five years but solutions and
that's really what what we're
trying to engage here push the
industry push the technology
push all the stakeholders and
make sure that we're looking
at Bible solutions on the
shortest possible time right to
reduce so the horrific things
that we see we get the more we
understand those interaction
the more we understand the
data the science so that we
can help direct solutions the
better off that we're going
to be so dependent a lawsuit
that's gonna drive changes
faster but I would hope we
would all feel that if it is
in the need for looking for
solutions as soon as we can
because what's at stake is
really cute and it's not just
for California than the lawsuit
is gonna direct this board with
California's solutions but it
is a west coast challenge it's
a much broader challenges we
seem to be finding ourselves
whether it's a climate any
number of areas engaged in and
solutions that are beyond just
California by the west coast
but even internationals we
look at the ocean acidification
and other changes that are
that are going on so this is
I think a right time for us
to be having these discussions
looking for solutions and you
have to sort out that lawsuit
in the District Court will sort
that out for the meantime we
still have our work cut out
thank you Mister vice chair
I think my only comment to be
this is that -- know that all
sides are talking -- which I
think is the best way to go to
find a solution -- I actually
think that there are common
goals -- from all sides -- and
there may be some different
paths to get their -- when I'm
open is that we're gonna be
able to -- all move forward
eventually together I do have
to say I think that -- where
CVD has been -- wanting to the
state data will put words in
your mouth -- but at the nay
particular that take permits
I think that is an important
first step -- above and beyond
what is already been happening
with -- legislative solution
-- so looking at a legislative
solution I think we need to be
able to continue to invest in
resources and moving with our
federal partners I to be able
to afford on that take for me
-- it's well I think it's a
three pronged approach again
I am not gonna waited to the
matters that are at hand of
both sides -- take a look for
any closing comments alternate
over to -- first since --
recent start with sort of
analytical street Christopher
political certainly thank you
senator -- briefly I what we
heard from director Bonham
today without launching into
a a path forward a solution
may include the take the
application for an is nothing
for me get I believe that with
the state being in the driver's
seat that effort -- I want
speaker CVD in this case but
certainly from our perspective
it is far more favorable to be
able to be full participants
in that application process
having the confidence to know
that having worked with the
state they want the commercial
fishery to be part of this
process and I think it we've
heard it from the feds we've
heard it from the state
certainly from scientists and
folks who work at the working
group at the working group is
a superior option that it is
the format by which in this
fishery in potential in the
west coast regionally we will
best be able to address these
challenges so I I think I'm
curious to see next steps in
the process but it you know at
this point I'm confident in the
state's strategy here and --
we look forward to working with
our friends and see if that we
on this of selling a lot more
work to come percent thank you
and yeah and I don't have much
more to to add but I I I would
note that we do see promise
in in the in the ramp program
but we do you really want to
see science bees management
measures that significantly
reduce the risk of entanglement
and do so very quickly it's
unfortunate that we're now
talking about this the end
of of twenty eighteen when we
were first raising this issue
and in twenty eight twenty
fourteen and that the amount
of time it's taken us to get
to to this point it's been too
long particularly when you're
talking about the populations
that we are the wheels just
don't have time to wait nor nor
should pay the state really has
a legal and moral obligation
to step up and really make
some significant changes but
also a great opportunity to
do so as has been reiterated
today several times thank you
so like you very very grateful
thank you for your comments
thank you both for being here
truly appreciate your work
and know that there's more
to come on this one thank you
so much both you not to be
moving on to public comment
we're gonna invite anyone
and everyone to be able to
come up and offer any public
comment -- here if you could
step up to the microphone
here two minutes okay
the wind is given is your first
name in your organization we
welcome you Sir good afternoon
chairman and co chair -- my
name's James McFarlane I'm
with the a marine of Tasmania
Australia and I'd like to thank
all of the fishers who have
gone out and worked with us
in the original test programs
I'd offer up couple couple
starts to go with my written
notes -- one is everything you
put over the side of the boat
is mission driven and those
pieces of equipment all have
different uses and so reckless
gears and the answer by itself
GPS tracking by itself is not
the answer -- the numbers of
entanglements globally are
three hundred thousand that's
the global number that they're
putting forth right now so
it's not just a California --
problems like you said we don't
have -- boundaries and so forth
as the global temperatures
change in the ocean the fishing
grounds are gonna change server
the feeding grounds and so we
do have these conflicts between
the mammals and and the fishers
I mean it's it's of no one no
one problem and it's going to
keep going on until we find
solutions what we would like
to -- hope is that we can work
together to the system finding
solutions for this and offer up
the following Jeff -- Chester
mentioned in his presentation
six bows with five traps each
to go into a an operational
pilot test program there's two
hundred thousand traps off the
coast of California annually
so we're talking about putting
thirty robust gear and to try
and find out what the problems
are because I heard from a
number of presenters that we
don't have the data to make --
informed decisions as to what
the right way forward is and
so -- here would love to help
-- I think a big job in front
of you and I think that the
ongoing conversation between
all of the interested parties
is in the best interest of
the state and that the wheels
that are here thank you so
much thank you for being here
afternoon thank you bring
in with this first last name
organization thank you again
for your time thank you so much
-- senator McGuire and assembly
member stone for having this
wonderful hearing today for
low everyone speak my name is
Leah Sturgis I'm speaking on
behalf of social compassionate
legislation and I did the
presentation I presented the
power point on will and see
totaling tangle men at the
budget subcommittee where the
seven point five million in
funds were appropriated to
the OPC -- and much of the
discussion was focused on
funding large larger scale
testing a robust gear and other
innovations the testimony that
day was focused on presenting
rebels technology as a solution
and the conversation is what
prompted the unit unanimous
approval of the budget
subcommittee so it was really
focused on tack in science
-- and so I feel there's no
doubt that the best solution
here will come from science
and technology technological
innovations afters considerable
investigation into this issue
I feel conceptually row plus
options are the only way to
eliminate risk of entanglement
and insensitive feeding areas
while allowing fishermen to
continue to make a living --
I also want to stress the dire
situation of the sea turtles
are facing we don't get the
same price as the whales but
their situation is actually
more critical and I'd like
to urge the committee to
make sure that funding be set
aside for Scott Benson here
at no and moss landing marine
laboratories so he can continue
to do his necessary serving
and tracking of the sea turtles
which is incredibly important
at this time the circles come
all the way from Indonesia to
feed in the Monterey Bay so
at least we can let them for
is there safely thank you so
much because which these pretty
amazing to think though about
their journey right in but it
takes absolutely thank you so
much we're grateful you're here
today please get your first
and last and your organization
we're grateful you're here
shore -- Nicholas Sackett
director of legislative affairs
for social question legislation
as well thinking not just once
a simply -- point out that
my organizations presentation
which was done by Leah on
April twenty third in front
of the budget sub committee
chaired by some members bloom
and where assemblymember
Tang is an alternate focus
solely on -- entanglement
issues and the possibility
of reducing doesn't hang
with with the use of reverse
gear and other technologies
after a presentation on four
twenty three the subcommittee
unanimously voted to approve
the seven point five million
dollars are allocated for him
issues on may twenty second
we fully understand that those
funds were not specifically
earmarked for broke with
testing but it's important
for all the stakeholders
including OPC in the working
group to understand the
spirit in which those funds
are allocated -- we believe
that the people of California
would be disappointed to know
that a method by which --
the fishery could thrive with
zero entanglements with the
use of reckless gear was not
at least tested by the state
if not outright advocate for
-- are asking is that the --
PC -- will commit to a robust
operational testing plan for
next season -- and to make
that commitment immediately so
that there is time to set up
a scientifically operationally
sound testing plan thanks
thank you so much thank you for
your comments today we really
appreciate you being here
welcome Sir correcting they
can bring in with us if you can
please give us your first and
last name your organization my
name is don't complain and I
am a commercial fisherman from
half moon bay and have been
for forty six years it up I
would like to thank you for the
opportunity to speak here today
and I would also like to is it
too thank you senator McGuire
in the committee for the
due diligence that -- you've
exhibited towards working
two viable solutions to the
problems involving demo casted
and willing paying with that
that still maintain focus on
vibrant sustainable fisheries
--
it's it's important to
commercial fisherman
how important it is to -- to
maintain a healthy Ocean for
all of its inhabitants in
fact I think it's fair to say
that we would have we have a
little patch of green on all
of this when it concerns to
the ocean our ocean activities
we just keep it well hidden
but where the rubber meets
the road through -- efforts
of Noah and sick before him PC
effort say the working group
it cetera -- it's it should be
clear that when it comes to the
rubber meeting the road we've
always been the first to step
up to the plate and take the
necessary steps the leaders to
productive full co existence
on the ocean with all of its
inhabitants thank you thank you
so much thank you for coming
over today as well retrievals
good to see you good afternoon
hereby give us your first and
last year musician it's good
to see you experiment thank
you things for the sun -- my
name's John Miller I'm a member
of the SF traveled owners
association yeah also a member
of the working group yeah I've
been fishing for forty years I
started when I was fifteen or
so -- I think the the exciting
thing about -- you know are
working group in this -- ramp
program specifically is just
the idea that fishermen can be
involved in our own governments
so it's not like it or coming
to you and saying okay give us
a solution I think ultimately
you know with the aid of
technology and -- you know all
these innovations and so forth
ultimately the solutions out
to come from the fishermen's
selves because if it doesn't
work for us result in a go
out of business in your house
vision ports with no picture
more and you know its -- that's
a terrible thing to imagine for
so many different reasons so I
think it -- you know we're used
to a sort of more heavy handed
top down style management --
coming from the agencies and
stuff and this is completely
different so because of that
I think you get a lot of by
incomplete because it has a lot
of credibility with the flea
and I think people are gonna
try a lot harder and racked
their brains to come up with
solutions and to actually see
it through and make it work so
thank you tell the to taking
time Sir in forty years that's
fantastic yeah I think thank
you very much it's good to see
you thanks rainy with this Hey
good afternoon ma'am thank you
so much for being here if you
just give us your first and
last organization my first name
is Catherine last name is quick
were -- a and been working for
several months pro bono with
a start up company in Halifax
Nova Scotia that is developing
a real close fishing solution
with GPS tracking and what
I'd like to let you know is
that the government of Canada
department of fisheries and
oceans has provided funding to
fishing associations to conduct
pilot testing of this and other
similar technologies and I I
really like that because it's
not just come the government
funding the company directly
but it's funding association to
get their members to take the
boats out and test equipment
and get really good feedback
from the fishermen whether it
works for them or not it has
to work for them and has to fit
on the deck the stackable allow
them to get the stuff in the
water without taking a fishing
gloves off and everything else
I have to deal with so I think
I would like to see of funding
solution in California that
does something similar piloting
through the Fishman says CH
thank you very much of a sick
you will definitely research
that I'm very grateful if you
don't mind just giving Mister
Wesley your card today that be
fantastic sure of three thank
you thank you very much for
being here thanks for hanging
thank you to see if anyone else
would like to be able to offer
their common their concerns or
criticisms into last call for
public comment can come on up
with up to be out here for me
alright I we're gonna
bring it back to committee
in look for some closing
comments from the vice chair
just like state thank you chair
for convening this and for
everyone who came in and spoke
to us today time is critical
on these issues and for to
continue the conversation
finding the solutions we
headed to your next legislative
session thanks so much as
vice chair you can ask for a
better partner in this in this
one say thank you to the vice
chair for all as advocacy it
is tied for the coast as well
-- very grateful by to be work
with you Sir we also want to
say thank you to all of you
for being with us -- you of
-- been fantastic and want to
say thank you to our panelists
as well Lewis a thank you to
Senate media services have been
streaming this live as well as
our sergeants were here today
and would like to read a map
out a little bit about -- road
map as we move forward in two
thousand nineteen within the
first quarter of two thousand
nineteen we're going to be
having hearing on offshore
wind there are several projects
off the state of California
that maybe dancing offshore
wind we want to make sure that
fisheries are natural resources
are protected while also being
-- provide that green energy
that the state station needs
to will be hosting a hearing on
that within the first quarter
of two thousand nineteen will
be following up on this issue
of wailing tangle me as well
as ship strikes here in two
thousand nineteen as well with
the understanding that there
is a lady active litigation
is being that will be moving
forward -- and we're hoping
that there's gonna be some type
of settlement I do not know
anything that you don't know
and I don't have a crystal ball
-- area and -- what I would
hope is that bottom line is
this we need to ensure that
we're protecting California's
majestic well population in
to be able to allow the crab
fishery to thrive in the years
to come I think that we can
have both -- in it's gonna
take compromise on all sides
be able to do so I to better
protect that well population
as well as a hard working men
and women in the fleet and I
am confident that we're gonna
be able to get there but I do
know that there's going to have
to be at some additional focus
that focus is gonna be detailed
in additional funding at the
state needs to be able to step
up and assist -- not just that
hundred thousand dollars and
on going -- -- allocation we
need to be able to step up on
more than a hundred thousand
dollars -- every year on well
tangle but no that's gonna
be budget discussion but
more to come number two on
the -- department of public
health we have to find the
department of public health
when it comes to testing on
that issue we will not get into
was cut out of the budget was
recommended by the legislature
by two years ago on the and
incredibly frustrating that
said we're gonna be going back
at it -- and hope that we can
work with the administration
to be successful this year
-- on securing those funds
for department public health
because it was -- it bipolar
we find in the department of --
at fish wildlife to we didn't
find public health doesn't
work when you only find one
of the team so that's more of
of more to come here out with
that again thank you all for
taking the time big thank you
to Mister Tom was slow for
all of his work -- in very
grateful for him where is our
chief consultant in who is the
rock of this committee so very
grateful Mister west low also
want to say thank you to Carly
revision within deal with all
logistics as well I think we
need to give time and curling
around of applause please
in -- without further do we
are going to invite all of you
to enjoy some of the best of
California's ocean -- fresh
from the Pacific we got oysters
and crab so we're gonna be
putting about here we encourage
you to be able to hang out
with us -- and enjoy some fresh
sustainable crap as well some
oysters -- area and -- the vice
chair is going to have a new
-- or Easter shooter contests
momentarily I write okay just
got awkward so I think you so
much everybody and we'll see
you -- here in the first part
two thousand nineteen thank
you to the aquarium of the
bay for all of their work in
partnership thank you Richard